Welcome everyone to another episode of Programming Throwdown. Hard to believe we're on 136. I think I say that every time now. Yeah, the time continues to fly. The direction of time is an arrow. No, no, okay, sorry. Time flies like a banana or something, or is that fruit flies like a banana? That's, okay, you're over my head now. All right, well, welcome. we're here on a what i think is going to be a really awesome episode talk about i guess you know sometimes we we see those
欢迎收看又一期的 Programming Throwdown。真不敢相信我们已经做到第 136 期了。我想我现在每次都这么说。是的，时间飞逝。时间的箭头是有方向的。不，不，好吧，抱歉。光阴似箭，或者说时光飞逝如香蕉？或者那是果蝇像香蕉？这个嘛，好吧，你现在把我问倒了。好的，欢迎来到这里。我认为这将是非常棒的一期节目，我们要谈论的是，你知道，有时候我们会看到那些
list of buzzwords and a lot of times they just wash over us you don't know necessarily what they mean but we have someone who has made it their current mission to tackle what is the metaverse and to build out a part of that and to just, you know, be immersed in it. So I think they're going to help us on our journey of going from metaverse as a, as a buzzword, and something that I think I've read in a couple science fiction books into, you know, bringing it down to earth. And what does it mean today? And what does it mean to be sort of like working in the metaverse? And where are we at in that journey to this cultural idea, I guess? Okay, that was a lot. That was a big setup.
一连串的流行语，很多时候它们只是从我们耳边呼啸而过，你不一定知道它们是什么意思。但我们有一位嘉宾，他目前的使命就是解决“什么是元宇宙”这个问题，构建其中的一部分，并且，你知道的，全身心投入其中。所以我认为他们将帮助我们开启这段旅程，把元宇宙从一个流行语，以及我认为我在几本科幻小说里读到的概念，转变为脚踏实地的现实。它今天意味着什么？在元宇宙中工作是怎样一种体验？我们距离实现这个文化愿景还有多远？好吧，信息量有点大。这是一个很大的开场。
All right, I think I'm going to introduce the co-founder and CEO of Topia. Daniel, welcome to the show, Daniel. Hey, thanks for having me. I'm pretty fired up to be here. All right. Well, I did have a pretty big setup, so we've got a lot to cover. But before then, I mean, tradition is we kind of always start with people's, you know, kind of like story, their origin story, right? Every good superhero always has to not. We are going to sort of, you know, kind of how you got into tech. Like, where did being interested in this crazy world of tech start for you? And it could be like, first time you had a computer or learned programming or just like,
好了，我想我要介绍一下 Topia 的联合创始人兼首席执行官。丹尼尔，欢迎来到节目，丹尼尔。嘿，谢谢邀请我。我非常兴奋能来到这里。好的。嗯，我的开场白确实挺长的，所以我们要聊的内容很多。不过在此之前，按照传统，我们通常都是从人们的故事开始，也就是他们的起源故事，对吧？每个伟大的超级英雄都有一个——不对。我们要聊聊你是怎么进入科技行业的。比如，你对这个疯狂的科技世界的兴趣是从哪里开始的？这可能比如是你第一次拥有一台电脑，或者学习编程，或者仅仅是……
what is a memory for you that you feel is like, oh yeah, that's when I kind of got bit by this bug? Yeah, I was a gamer as long as I can remember, from as young as I can recall really doing anything. I had a computer. I was playing games. My parents encouraged me when I was younger,, I was playing games, my parents encouraged me when I was younger, when I was very young to play things like Math Blaster and games like that,
对你来说，哪个记忆让你觉得，“哦，对，这就是我当年被这个病毒击中的时候”？是的，只要我能记事起，自我能记事起真正开始做任何事情开始，我就是一个游戏玩家。我有一台电脑。我在玩游戏。我父母在我很小的时候就鼓励我，当我非常小的时候，他们鼓励我玩一些像 Math Blaster 这样的游戏，诸如此类的游戏，
you know, to really date myself. But you know, I also started experimenting with programming languages like QBasic really early on and actually trying to build my own video games, even when I was like, seven, eight years old, I think. And I did that with a friend. And that was sort of the origin of my deep appreciation for computing and for the ability to be a sourcer and actually conjure something from scratch if you have some technical capabilities. And then in high school, I took programming classes. I built some RPGs in Java. I was also building websites for myself and for others. And dabbling with entrepreneurship, I had a slew of failed startups when I was in my youth.
你知道，这真的很暴露我的年龄。但你知道，我也很早就开始尝试 QBasic 这样的编程语言，实际上还尝试自己制作电子游戏，甚至在我大概七、八岁的时候吧，我想。我和一个朋友一起做了这件事。那就是我对计算机的深厚欣赏以及作为一名源术士（sourcer）的能力的起源——如果你具备一些技术能力，就能凭空召唤出一些东西。然后上高中时，我上了编程课。我用 Java 制作了一些 RPG 游戏。我还为自己和他人搭建网站。并涉足创业，我年轻时经历过一连串失败的初创公司。
And kind of bringing those two passions together. I was also, I played some sports and did outdoorsy things, but you know, my real passion was, uh, was games. And in particular, I got pretty deep into MMOs, uh, Star Wars galaxies, EverQuest before that. And those kinds of experiences, you know, you were kind of coming together real time with other people across the internet. I did that with some of my friends from high school, Galaxies in particular, we played pretty religiously, but also with strangers and forming clans. Clans was a big thing in sort of the 90s and early 2000s when I was doing a lot of this. And the idea of building community online with other real humans and then interacting synchronously was just kind of mind-blowing. So I know we're going to get into the metaverse, but that for me is actually the origin of my
把这两种热情结合起来。我也，我参加过一些体育运动，也做过户外活动，但你知道，我真正的热情是游戏。特别是，我深入涉足了大型多人在线游戏（MMO），《星球大战：银河系》，之前的《无尽的任务》。这些类型的经历，你知道，你通过互联网与来自各地的其他人实时聚集在一起。我和高中时的一些朋友一起玩，特别是《银河系》，我们玩得相当虔诚，但也和陌生人一起玩并组建公会。在90年代和2000年代初我经常做这些事情的时候，公会是一件大事。与其他真实人类在网上建立社区然后同步互动的想法简直太震撼了。所以我知道我们要进入元宇宙的话题，但对我来说，这实际上是我
interest in this idea of the evolution of the internet into something that's more synchronous. And I remember even when I was really young, telling my parents about the kinds of things I was doing online where I was building businesses in Star Wars galaxies and I had a clan and a whole community and they were they thought I was you know uh either onto something and this is going to be an amazing outcome for my life or I was going down a spirally pit and they had no idea really what to do I would say that's everybody's current conversation whenever someone brings up cryptocurrency you either know something or you're crazy absolutely all right well that was that was awesome wow you kind of did my job for me you like really set that all up and and got it going uh do you remember what your first computer was some people do and some people don't
对互联网演变成更具同步性事物的兴趣的起源。我记得甚至在我很小的时候，我就把我在网上做的事情告诉我的父母，我在《星球大战：银河系》里建立企业，我有一个公会和整个社区，他们当时认为我，你知道，要么是搞出了什么名堂，这对我的人生将是一个惊人的结果，要么是我正在走向一个螺旋式下坠的深渊，他们真的不知道该怎么办。我要说的是，每当有人提起加密货币时，大家的反应都是当前的对话：要么你懂点什么，要么你就是个疯子。绝对是这样。好吧，那真的很棒，哇，你基本上替我把工作做了，你把那些都铺垫好了并让它运转起来。你还记得你的第一台电脑是什么吗？有些人记得，有些人不记得。
wow that's a good question i don't actually recall what it was no no no no that's all right some people have this like really big attachment like to the specifics of of their computer i think that it also at some point kind of shifted into what do you call like a white box pc and it was like i don't know it's just like a pc i don't know yeah i'm definitely in that other camp i still have my commodore 64 it doesn't work but i just can't throw it out it's just it's sitting in a closet and I don't have the heart to put it to pasture. But yeah, I mean, the age you described, you know, when MMOs first started being a thing, not only could you play a game, you could play a game online. And not only was it like, oh, I'm just going to shoot my friends. And this is hilarious because multiplayer is, and Quake is awesome.
哇，这是个好问题。我实际上不记得那是什么了，不，不，不，没关系。有些人对他们的电脑的细节有着非常深厚的感情。我觉得它在某种程度上也转变成了你所说的白盒 PC，就好像，我不知道，它只是一台 PC，我不知道。是的，我绝对属于另一阵营。我仍然保留着我的 Commodore 64，它虽然坏了，但我就是舍不得扔掉。它就放在衣橱里，我实在狠不下心让它退役。但是，是的，你描述的那个年龄，当 MMO 刚开始流行时，你不仅可以玩游戏，还可以在线玩游戏。这不仅像是“哦，我要去射击我的朋友，这太好笑了，因为多人游戏和《雷神之锤》太棒了”。
But, you know, actually like go on adventures together and story build together and you know just get immersed into this was a a crazy time even even today i think i've never played eve online but i'm like envious of the people that just have this like deep ingrained passion i like read the after after battle reports and i'm just like this sounds so exciting and i watch a youtube video getting started i'm like i don I don't know. But yeah, that whole thing is, I could totally see what you're describing about how like formative that is and getting involved and going down that path. So that's really awesome. Yeah, I've tried to EVE, I tried to start EVE a couple times, start my life. And each time I just couldn't quite get over the learning curve of it.
但是，你知道，实际上是一起去冒险，一起构建故事，你知道，只是沉浸其中，这是一个疯狂的时刻。甚至在今天，我想我从来没玩过《EVE Online》，但我很嫉妒那些对此有着深厚刻骨热情的人。我喜欢阅读战后报告，我就觉得这听起来太刺激了。我看了一个入门的 YouTube 视频，然后我想，我不知道。但是，是的，整件事就是，我完全能理解你所描述的这种经历是多么具有塑造性，如何参与其中并走上那条道路。所以这真的很棒。是的，我尝试过 EVE，我试过好几次开始玩 EVE，开始我的生活。每一次我都无法完全克服它的学习曲线。
The same is true for me in Dwarf Fortress. But that's another topic for another time. I had the same experience with Eve, but I did sink a ton of time in a Dwarf Fortress. Probably an embarrassing amount of time into Dwarf Fortress. Yeah, it's really hard now that they've decided to add hour counters to all of the gaming things and tell you how many hours you've played. don't appreciate this all right cool so so yeah so you started programming at a young age and you talked about you know kind of doing stuff in cube basic i feel like that's a story uh similar for me i remember having a programming calculator in high school and like
我在《矮人要塞》（Dwarf Fortress）上也是如此。但那是另一个话题了。我和 EVE 有着同样的经历，但我确实在《矮人要塞》上倾注了大量的时间。可能是在《矮人要塞》上花费了令人尴尬的大量时间。是的，现在所有的游戏平台都决定添加小时计数器来告诉你玩了多少小时，这真的很让人头疼。真不习惯这个。好了，酷。所以，是的，你很小的时候就开始编程了，你谈到了在 QBasic 中做一些事情。我觉得这个故事对我也很相似。我记得在高中时有一台可编程计算器，就像
programming just dumb little games to you know occupy my time but like you said you kind of equated it to sorcery i mean i think it's it's funny because people outside of uh computers and programming view it that way but i think even inside you're right like it still feels that way sometimes that like you can just program some simple rules or even just an algorithm you think is supposed to work. And you're like, wait, that didn't work or it didn't do what I was supposed to. Oh, it's smarter than me or it's not as smart. It's crazy sometimes how you think it takes on a life of its own. Absolutely. Yeah. And it's part of the motivation as I got older.
编写一些愚蠢的小游戏来打发时间。但就像你说的，你把它比作巫术（sorcery）。我的意思是，我觉得这很有趣，因为计算机和编程之外的人是这样看待它的，但我觉得即使在内部，你是对的，有时它仍然有这种感觉，就像你只需编写一些简单的规则，甚至只是一个你认为应该起作用的算法。然后你会想，等等，那不管用，或者它没有按我预期的那样做。哦，它比我更聪明，或者它没有那么聪明。有时你会觉得它有了自己的生命，这真是太疯狂了。绝对的。是的，这是我年龄增长后的部分动力。
I did a little bit of a detour. I went into finance. We can talk about that. I was at Lehman Brothers. I was an investor in VC. And then I went back into programming. And the reason really is I missed being able to create things and conjure things. And really, when you're a programmer, But, you know, you have the ability once you're technical to actually just manifest whatever it is that you can imagine. And your imagination is really the only limiter. And to me, that is just an incredible thing that that's possible in the world. That's actually a great point. So yeah, to dive in that one second. So you went into finance and obviously into VC, you're no longer there. I feel like that's a world that I know a few people who have left finance and come to just the broader programming world. But I mean, do you have any just kind of like words of wisdom or observations about the difference of sort of being a tech person or programming inside of finance for sound or is it overdone? It's really just the same thing.
我走了一点弯路。我进入了金融界。我们可以谈谈这个。我在雷曼兄弟（Lehman Brothers）。我是一名风投（VC）投资人。然后我又回到了编程。原因其实是我怀念能够创造事物和变出事物的能力。真的，当你是一名程序员时，但是，你知道，一旦你具备了技术能力，你就有能力将你能想象到的任何东西具象化。你的想象力真的是唯一的限制。对我和我来说，这简直是一件不可思议的事情，在世界上这是可能的。这确实是一个很好的观点。所以，深入探讨这一点。所以你进入了金融界，显然加入了 VC，你现在不在那里了。我觉得这是一个我知道一些离开金融界并来到更广泛的编程世界的人的领域。但是，作为一个科技人或者在金融内部进行编程，与在其他地方相比，你有什么智慧的话语或观察吗？还是说这被夸大了？其实都一样。
Well, I actually was not a programmer inside of finance. I completely left programming, essentially. I mean, I was still a wizard at Excel macros and that sort of stuff. But I was a traditional investment banker for Lehman and then Barclays once Lehman went under. And then in my VC role, I was an investor. I was not really doing programming. Again, I was doing a lot of little interesting hacks with Excel and basically building applications within my role, but that wasn't actually what I was supposed to be doing. And I really did that because I love creating things, but I want to understand how businesses work and how accounting works and, you know, be a little bit more full stack.
嗯，其实我并没有在金融界从事编程工作。我完全放弃了编程，基本上是这样。我的意思是，我仍然是 Excel 宏等方面的专家。但我曾是雷曼兄弟的传统投资银行家，在雷曼倒闭后则是巴克莱银行的传统投资银行家。然后在我的 VC 角色中，我是一名投资者。我并没有真正做编程。再次说明，我在 Excel 中做了一些有趣的小黑客操作，并在我的角色中基本上构建了应用程序，但这并不是我当时应该做的事情。我这样做真的是因为我喜欢创造事物，但我想了解商业是如何运作的，会计是如何运作的，并且，你知道，成为一个更全栈的人。
I actually look at my own life as a video game, right? Like an RPG, right? And so you have different skill trees and you can gain experience and level up these different skills and specialize in things. And so, you know, I've kind of been on a quest, on many quests throughout my life to just gain as many of these skills as possible so that I could be, you know, sort of like a multidisciplinary entrepreneur and creator and sourcer and whatever, you know, whatever you want to call it. Oh, interesting. So you were there though,
我实际上把自己的生活看作是一个视频游戏，对吧？就像一个 RPG，对吧？所以你有不同的技能树，你可以获得经验并升级这些不同的技能，并专精于某些事物。所以，你知道，我一生中一直在进行各种探索，进行许多探索，以尽可能多地获得这些技能，这样我就可以成为，你知道，某种多学科的企业家和创作者和源术士（sourcer），或者随便你怎么称呼它。哦，有趣。不过你当时在那里，
right around the financial collapse then? I mean, do you have any horror stories about that? That is off topic, but... Yeah, I was at I was at Lehman, uh, as it collapsed, essentially. I was actually an intern, um, to be fair. And they gave, you know, the writing was on the wall that summer. It was during the, you know, Bear Stearns went under, um, and everybody was panicking. So normally they gave like 98% of interns full-time offers in my In my year, they gave like 15%, something like that. And I was fortunate enough to get a full-time offer. But then when I went back to school, Lehman collapsed. And I was like, all right, I'm going to move to China and become a Shaoling monk.
对吧，就在金融危机爆发的时候？我的意思是，你有什么关于那件事的恐怖故事吗？这虽然有点跑题，但是……是的，我在雷曼兄弟倒闭时就在那里，基本上是这样。公平地说，我当时其实是一名实习生。他们给出了，那个夏天墙上写着字，那是当贝尔斯登（Bear Stearns）倒闭的时候，每个人都在恐慌。所以通常他们会在我的那一年给大概 98% 的实习生全职录用通知，但他们只给了大概 15%，诸如此类。我很幸运地得到了一个全职录用通知。但当我回到学校时，雷曼倒闭了。当时我想，好吧，我要搬去中国，当一个少林和尚。
That was actually my plan. And then Barclays acquired some of the employees, including me. And so I went and did that there. And I was a healthcare... I started as a healthcare investment banker. When I went into VC, I was focused on healthcare software as a service. And then I left that in 2013 to just be like, all right, I'm just going to go back to pure full-time building.
这其实是我的计划。然后巴克莱银行收购了一些员工，包括我。所以我去了那里并在那里工作。我是一名医疗保健……我最初是一名医疗保健投资银行家。当我进入风投行业时，我专注于医疗保健软件即服务（SaaS）。然后我在 2013 年离开，心想，好吧，我要回去全身心投入纯粹的开发。
I went to a coding bootcamp called Hack Reactor and learned a lot of the modern frameworks like JavaScript, Node, a lot of Java. It was very JavaScript-based coding bootcamp. And then from there, I just, basically for the next decade, I just built things. And I had a dev shop. I had my first, what is now referred to
我参加了一个名为 Hack Reactor 的编程训练营，并学习了许多现代框架，如 JavaScript、Node、大量的 Java。这是一个非常以 JavaScript 为主的编程训练营。然后从那里开始，基本上在接下来的十年里，我一直在构建各种东西。我开过一家开发公司。在 2015 年，我拥有了现在被称为元宇宙平台的第一个产品。它叫做 Body，它是健身教练教授实时互动课程、建立自己的品牌健身工作室、围绕其建立社区的一种方式，我游历了世界。我是一个数字游民。我曾在巴厘岛和泰国的社区生活，我也在旧金山、纽约、洛杉矶生活过。是的，这就是我的历史。哇。这真是一段史诗般的旅程，我想。所以你对 RPG 的生活真的是认真的，我想。绝对是的。好了，酷。所以，我的意思是，我认为我们对……嗯，也许不是很有感觉，但我们至少对那里的情况有了个大概的了解。那么是什么促使你，你开始谈论建立数字世界，关于元宇宙并接触到这些。你当前努力的起源是什么？所以，你知道，再次像那个 RPG 一样，我多年来一直在为此努力，包括在 2015 年使用非常相似技术的初创公司。
as the Metaverse platform in 2015. It was called Body and it was a way for fitness instructors to teach live interactive classes, create their own branded fitness studios, build community around it, and I traveled the world. I was a digital nomad. I lived in communities in Bali and Thailand, and I lived in San Francisco, New York, LA. And yeah, that's kind of my history. Wow. That is quite an epic journey, I guess. So you really were serious about the life as an RPG, I guess. Absolutely. All right, cool. So I mean, all mean, I think we have a feel for like, well, maybe not a feel, but we at least have had a glimpse of getting there. So what led you to kind of, you started talking about building kind of like digital worlds, about the metaverse and getting encounters with this. What was the genesis of your current endeavor? So, you know, again, kind of like that RPG, I've been building towards this for many, many years, including in 2015 with the startup that was using very similar technology.
所以，你知道，我认为这是多种因素结合的结果，但这个核心想法是，互联网将从像电子邮件那样异步的事物演变而来。你写点东西，然后过一段时间，别人回信。甚至是 Facebook 的留言板也是异步的。并更多地向我们几十年来通过 MMO 体验到的那种体验、社区和连接演变。我对此有着坚定的信念。事实上，在那个旅程中，我曾被你所尊敬的人告知这不是真的，他们会觉得，“好吧，那个人其实真的很懂”。在 2015 年左右的时候，这是一个非常不受欢迎的观点，当时人们认为互联网的真正
So, you know, I think it's a combination of a few things, but it's this idea that the internet is going to evolve from something that was asynchronous, like email. You write something, and then sometime later, somebody writes back. Even a Facebook wall is asynchronous. And evolve more towards the kinds of experiences and community and connection that we've had with MMOs for decades now. And I've had a lot of conviction around that. And I've actually, in that journey, have been told that that's not true by people that you would respect and be like, okay, that person actually really knows. It was a very unpopular opinion in 2015-ish timeframe, where people thought that the real
杠杆作用将变得更加异步，对吧？如果你想想 TikTok 之类的东西，例如，那是真的，对吧？在像 TikTok 这样的异步社交平台中确实有很多杠杆作用。但现实是，互联网有机会成为更具连接性的东西，能够更密切地模拟我们在现实生活中的连接方式。所以这对我来说感觉就像，为什么人们看不到这是不可避免的？我们已经在 MMO 中拥有它了。显然，这将用于生产力、远程工作、远程社区和娱乐。
leverage of the internet was going to be to become more asynchronous, right? And if you think about things like TikTok, for example, that is true, right? There is a lot of leverage in sort of async social platform like TikTok. But the reality is that there's an opportunity for the internet to be something that is more connective, that more closely emulates how we connect in real life. And so it just felt to me like, why do people not see that this is an inevitability? We already have it in MMOs. Clearly, this is going to be something that's going to be used for productivity, for remote work, for remote community and fun.
甚至非游戏玩家也将能够以游戏玩家目前通过多人游戏的方式相互互动。作为这种信念的一部分，我也生活在许多不同的社区中。我看到活动组织者、艺术家、创作者、音乐家、瑜伽教练真的在努力建立全球受众、建立全球社区、将人们聚集在一起以及进行数字营销等方面苦苦挣扎。所以我一直对尝试创建一个平台来帮助和赋能创作者充满热情。然后我想最后一部分是
And even non-gamers are going to be able to interact with each other in the way that gamers do right now through multiplayer. And so as part of that conviction, I also have lived in many different communities. I've seen organizers of events and artists and creators, musicians, yoga instructors really struggle to build a global audience and build a global community and bring people together and do digital marketing and those sorts of things. So I was always very passionate about trying to create a platform to help and empower creators. And then I guess the sort of like last piece of it is the
创建一个平台的想法，你可以在整个互联网上将你的社区带到一个平台上。所以当我们谈论元宇宙时，它是实时互联网和 Web3 的交集。我自 2012 年以来一直是一个去中心化后端或数据库的人，我投资了比特币。我在 2017 年是一名以太坊开发者。所以我也有涉足这些技术。我基本上将我所有的兴趣和热情融为一个统一的平台，也就是 Topia。我最初的计划是在 2020 年代构建这个平台，基本上让全世界能够协作在虚拟世界中创造社交体验，然后将社区聚集在一起。我原计划在 2020 年代这样做。我当时正在为此构建一个 VR 平台。我当时在构建一个基于浏览器的比特币闪电游戏，然后大流行袭来了。我意识到我没有
idea of creating something where you can bring your community to a platform across the entire internet. And so when we talk about metaverse, it's kind of the intersection of the real-time internet and Web3. And I've been a decentralized backend or database person since 2012 I invested in Bitcoin. I was an Ethereum developer in 2017. So I've kind of dabbled in these technologies as well. And I essentially smashed all of my interests and passions together into one unified platform, which is Topia. And my plan originally was to build this over the 2020s and basically make it so that the whole world could collaboratively create social experiences in virtual worlds and then bring community together. And I was planning on doing it in the 2020s. I had a VR platform I was building for this. I had a Bitcoin lightning game, browser-based game that I was building, and then the pandemic hit. And I realized I didn't have a
十年的时间来构建人们现在实际需要的东西。像火人节（Burning Man）这样我们在 2020 年共同主办、然后在 2021 年再次共同主办的活动，他们需要一种在线方式来做到这一点，而且感觉仍然像火人节。所以我基本上抛弃了我正在做的所有事情，从零开始，在第一行代码写完三周后推出了我们的第一次公开活动。剩下的，正如他们所说，就是历史了。
decade to build this thing that people actually needed it right now. And things like Burning Man, which we co-hosted in 2020, and then again in 2021, they needed a way to do this online in a way that still felt like Burning Man. And so I basically threw out everything I was doing, started from scratch and launched the, we had our first public event three weeks after the first line of code. And the rest, as they say, is history.
哦，哇。所以，当我听到你这样描述元宇宙时，它与我想象的不同，我想说的是每个人，但那不是真的。不是每个人。但我记得当《第二人生》（Second Life）推出时，每个人都说，哦，这将是重头戏。这就是未来。这就是那款产品。我如何看待《第二人生》以及你现在所描述的内容，这两者之间的区别之一是，对于不了解的人来说，它就像一个 3D 视频游戏，你有一个化身，你可以在一个不是我们的世界、而是一个不同世界的虚拟世界中四处移动。但是，我听到你现在描述的内容与《第二人生》相比的一个不同之处在于，它甚至体现在名字里。《第二人生》就像是另一种人生。你正在经历某种替代的，我要说的是幻想，但不是，
Oh, wow. So Metaverse, as I hear you describe it in telling this, different than I think maybe, I want to say everyone, but that's not true. Not everyone. But I remember when Second Life launched and everyone was like, oh, this is going to be the thing. This is the future. This is the thing. And one of the differences between how I view Second Life, which for people who don't know, was like a 3D video game where you had an avatar and you could move around in a world that was not our world, but a different world. But one of the things that is different from how here, I hear you describing what you're saying now versus like what second life was, is it is even kind of in the name. Second life is like an alternate life. You're living out some alternate, I'm going to say fantasy, but not,
你不应该是你自己。你应该假装成别人。你谈到了角色扮演游戏，一个游戏，对吧？即使它没有传统意义上的那种可能的游戏元素，它仍然意味着那种“你不是你自己”的形式。而你描述你正在做的事情的方式，就像一个举办像火人节这样活动的地方，好吧，我想其中也许也有一些注意事项。但就像，你知道，它更多的是让你与现实生活联系，但是在互联网上，对吧？就像你在构建社区时会做的事情一样。我听到你用听起来更像是替代你在现实生活中会做的事情的词语来谈论它，而不是像一个视频游戏。我是不是对这种界限的划分听得有点准确？你觉得有
you're not supposed to be who you are. You're supposed to be pretending to be someone else. And talked about a role-playing game, a game, right? Even if there's no traditional kind of maybe game elements to it, it was still meant to be that kind of not who you are. The way you're describing what you're saying, like a place to host something like Burning Man, well, I guess there's maybe some caveats in there as well. But like, you know, it's more you to connect with, like real life, but on the internet, right? Like something that you would do building a community. I hear you talk about it in terms that sound more like a replacement for something you would do in physical real person, rather than a video game. Am I sort of hearing that like, delineation correctly? Do you feel like there's
这两者之间有什么区别吗？是的，你在很多方面都一针见血。《第二人生》的创造者菲利普·罗斯代尔（Philip Rosedale）我非常尊重，他是我的朋友，还有约翰·扎诺夫斯基（John Zanowski），他曾担任过一段时间的首席财务官。他实际上是我们的首席财务官。所以我们对他们创造的东西有着深厚的根基。在很多方面，它是这个行业的鼻祖，也是我们正在做的事情的鼻祖。我认为对我们来说，正如你所说，重点较少放在化身上，而更多地放在人类连接上。这是我们思考产品构建时的原则之一。对我们来说，关乎人类连接、可访问性、创造更安全的空间以及内置于产品本身的同意机制。
a difference between those two? Yeah, I think you're hitting the nail on the head in many ways. And Second Life, I have a lot of respect for the creator of Second Life, Philip Rosedale, is a friend of mine, John Zanowski, who was the CFO for a period. He's actually our CFO. And so we have deep roots into what they created. And it's kind of the OG of this industry and of what we're doing in many ways. I think for us, it's less about focus on the avatar, as you said, and more on human connection. That's one of our principles when we think about building product. For us, it's about human connection, accessibility, and creating safer spaces and consent built into the product itself.
因此，对我们来说，真正的真人连接的想法，你需要真正看到其他人类并能够直视他们的眼睛，对吧？这是我们如何进化以真正彼此真实连接的一部分。所以对我们来说，我们实际上将化身抽象化了。有这些可爱的小东西，我们称之为 topis，它们是中性的。
And so for us, the idea of real human connection, you need to actually see other humans and be able to look them in the eyes, right? That's part of how we evolved to actually authentically connect with one another. And so for us, we actually kind of abstract away the avatar. There are these cute little, we call them topis, and they're androgynous.
它们本质上是没有性别的。你可以选择不同的颜色，然后你就在世界里走来走去，但它们基本上是你自己的化身，对吧？但它不是焦点。Topia 中的焦点是其他真实的人类。我们这样做的原因，再次说明，人类连接不是，我们不会考虑化身与化身之间的连接，而是考虑实际使用诸如
They're essentially genderless. You can select a different color and you just walk around the world, but they're basically an embodiment of yourself, right? But it's not the focal point. The focal point in Topia is the other actual humans. And the reason that we did that is, again, you know, human connection is not, we don't think about avatar to avatar connection, but instead about the ability to actually use things like
WebRTC（网页实时通信）之类技术的能力，来与其他人连接并看到他们，就像你在现实生活中一样。所以这对我们来说是很重要的。你刚才说我们正试图取代现实生活，我知道你不是直接那个意思，但我只想指出，我们的使命不是取代现实生活。我们在过去两年里共同主办了虚拟火人节，但现场火人节是我一直去的地方，我想，直到因为疫情暂停之前，我连续去了六年。我热爱现场，我热爱现实生活。但以火人节为例，每年有 7 万人可以去。而且非常昂贵。实际上大部分是旧金山
WebRTC, which is web real-time communication, to connect with other humans and see them as though you would in real life. So that's something that's important for us. You said we're trying to replace real life, and I know you didn't mean it directly that way, but I just want to point out that our mission is not to replace real life. We co-hosted Virtual Burning Man for the last two years, but in-person Burning Man is something that I've gone to for the last, I guess, until it was paused for pandemic, I went six years in a row. And I love in-person, I love real life. But Burning Man, as an example, 70,000 people a year can go. And it's very expensive. It's actually mostly San Francisco
人或富裕的科技人员能够接触到那个社区。这个想法应该让世界各地数以百万计的人都能访问，无论其社会经济背景如何。所以我们试图做的不是取代现实生活，而是增强对这些社区的访问，并创造可以存在于现实中和在线的混合体验和社区。坦率地说，你知道，可以存在于 Topia 的在线世界中，但也可以使用其他平台，使用像区块链这样的共享后端，将社区带到每一个存在的平台上，并真正拥有一个真正灵活且可扩展的社区生态系统。好吧，有趣。是的，所以对“取代”这个词的纠正很公正。所以我想，是的，关于“可以取代”与“真正取代”这一部分。所以我觉得，就像你提到的，我要这样做，不需要在现实生活中见面。也许对某些人或某些事情来说这是真的。但我觉得，正如你所提到的，这几乎是对你所做事情的一种增强。所以这不是对那些东西的替代，而是一种补充的方式。所以就像你提到的，当成本、疫情或某种障碍阻止你去某地时，这并不意味着你不能拥有
people or wealthy tech people that are able to access that community. And the idea of it should be accessible by millions of people all over the world, regardless of socioeconomic background. And so what we're trying to do is not replace real life, but instead enhance access to these communities and create hybrid experiences and communities that can exist in person and online. And frankly, you know, can exist online within Topia, but also can use other platforms using shared backends like blockchains to, you know, bring the community across every platform
线上同样或相似深度的体验。这算是一种更好的重新表述吗？是的，我认为这很公平。这不仅是一个障碍，如果你每季度和整个社区聚会一次，那会非常昂贵。人们必须飞来飞去。有了像 Topia 这样的东西，你可以亲自进行每季度的聚会，但你也可以每周或每天聚会，对吧？或者拥有一个持久的开放社区空间，有点像市政厅，人们可以随时来。好的。所以我想我大概理解了，
that exists and truly have a really flexible and scalable community ecosystem. Okay, interesting. Yeah, so fair call out on replacement. So I guess, yeah, this part about can replace versus does replace. So I feel that there's, like you mentioned, that I'm going to do this and not need to meet in real life. Maybe for some people or maybe for some things that's true. But I feel like this, like you're kind of mentioning, is almost an augmentation of what you do. So this isn't a replacement for that stuff, but a way to kind of complement it. So like you mentioned, when cost or pandemic or some barrier prevents you from being able to go somewhere, that doesn't mean you can't have the
但到目前为止，在我们讨论的关于你正在构建的元宇宙愿景中，人们在见面，我不想说就像为了某种事业或某种原因，听起来像是很有针对性的——比如我为了这个社区或这个东西来到这里——但当我听到它在更广泛的描述中被描述时，或者我们想到科幻小说——所以，我想也有一部电影，但还有书《头号玩家》（Ready Player One），或者我们可以追溯到《雪崩》（Snow Crash）——好吧，我们要开始进行科幻小说的离题讨论了。但是，如果你回想过去，人们想要并去到元宇宙这种持久的在线事物中，并不是出于任何特定原因，也许是为了娱乐，或者只是作为日常生活的一部分。所以你觉得
same or a similar depth of experience online. Is that a better rephrasing of it, I guess? Yeah, I think that's fair. It's also not just a barrier, but if you get together with your whole community once a quarter, it's very expensive. People have to fly in. With something like Topia, you can do that quarterly get-together in person, but you can also get together every week or every day, right? Or have a persistent open community space that's kind of like the town hall where people can just come whenever they want. All right. So I think I'm getting a picture,
元宇宙作为一个——比如，我去是有原因的，有需求的（需求这个词太强了），是一种做特定事情的渴望——与仅仅是一个去某个地方的地方之间有区别吗？你觉得这两者之间有区别吗？这就像是一个过渡吗？你对此有什么看法吗？是的，你知道，当你提起《头号玩家》时，这很有趣。我实际上把《头号玩家》视为一种非常反乌托邦的结果，人们不再亲自聚在一起。一切都在网上进行。我认为这不是我们在这里应该追求的目标。我认为这在某些方面会是一个失误。所以我不知道答案是它将是目标驱动的使用，还是仅仅成为一个你一直去的地方。我认为这
but what we've talked about so far in your vision of sort of the metaverse as you're building it out is people are meeting, I don't want to say like for a cause or for a reason like it sounds like targeted right like i go here for like this community or this thing but when i hear it described in the broader broader description or we think of like we mentioned sci-fi so uh i guess there was a movie as well but the book ready player one or we can go even further back to like snow crash and okay we're gonna get off on a sci-fi tangent. But like, if you go back, people wanted and went to kind of like the metaverse, the persistent online thing, for no reason in particular, but maybe for entertainment or just as part of an everyday thing. And so do you feel
可能是两者的混合，对吧？将会有特定的目的，就像我们现在开 Zoom 会议一样。这些都是非常具体的，对吧？你不会随随便便地进入一个 Zoom 聚会并在里面瞎胡闹，对吧？它们是会议。它们非常刻意。所以绝对有这样的情况。而在像 Topia 这样的事物中，有会议，有活动。某人带了一千人进来一起庆祝他们的 IPO。这些都是活动驱动的。所以你现在肯定有这个，将来也一定会有。我们也看到许多持久的空间，它们只是一些社区聚会场所。你下班后进去看看还有谁
like there's a difference between metaverse as a, like, I'm going for a reason a a need driven need is too strong a desire to do a specific thing versus just like a place to just go do you feel like there's a difference there it's like a transition do you have any thoughts about that yeah you know it's interesting when you bring up ready player one i actually look at ready player one as a very dystopian outcome where people no longer get together in person. Everything is conducted online. I don't think that's what we should be shooting for here. I think that would be a misfire in some ways. And so I don't know the answer to whether it's going to be purpose-driven usage or whether it's just going to be a place that you go all the time. I think it's
在那里。你在闲逛并有点放松，有点像你在大学里走到公共区域看看还有谁在那里的感觉。所以你也会看到这种更随意的、持久的闲逛。我认为这两者绝对都会存在。这将取决于个人。这将取决于你的用途。有趣的事情之一是，我们看到很多人，特别是在疫情期间，我们看到了很多远程工作，但没有那么多远程娱乐。这就是事情开始变得有趣的地方。
probably a hybrid of both, right? Where there are going to be specific purposes, kind of like how we do Zoom meetings right now. Those are all very specific, right? You don't like casually go into a Zoom hangout and just mess around in there, right? They're meetings. They're very intentional. So there are definitely cases like that. And in things like Topia, there are conferences, there are events. Somebody brings a thousand people in to celebrate their IPO together. Those are all very event-driven. And so you definitely have that now and you will for sure have that in the future. We also are seeing a lot of persistent spaces that are just kind of community hangouts. And you get off work, you go in and see who else
远程工作，每个人都知道，那显然会成为一种趋势。它已经是了。我们有许多生产力工具，如 Slack、Asana 等等，它们真正增强了我们远程工作的能力。但我们真正错过的是，如果你要远程并远程工作，你必须能够拥有远程社区、远程娱乐和远程闲逛，比如去酒吧，对吧？当你下班结束工作去欢乐时光（happy hour）时，这在历史上是一个在网上非常具有挑战性的体验。而这些正是
is there. You're hanging out and kind of relaxing, kind of like when you're in university and you go down to the common area and just see who else is there. So you kind of see that more casual, persistent hangout as well. And I think both of those will definitely exist. And it'll depend on the person. It'll depend on what you're using it for. One of the interesting things is that we see a lot of, especially during the pandemic, we saw a lot of remote work, but not as much remote play. And that's where things start getting kind of interesting.
我们正试图让人们能够轻易体验到的东西。有趣。所以，好吧，有很多内容需要消化，我想。但是，我听到的一点是，不同的社区和不同类型的事情正在你的脑海中发生。从……这是不是一个巨大的实例？哦，我们讨论过，你知道，类似于过去的游戏，对吧？
Remote work, everybody knows, obviously, that's going to be a thing. It already is. And we have a lot of productivity tools like Slack and Asana and whatnot that really enhance our ability to work remotely. But what we've really missed from that is if you're going to be remote and work remotely, you kind of need to be able to have remote community and remote play and remote hangout, like go to the bar, right? When you're done with work for happy hour, that is an experience that has been really challenging online historically. And those are the kinds of things
可能会有一个服务器 A、服务器 B 和服务器 C。你可以在一个服务器上，该服务器上的一切都是持久的和一致的，但与下一个服务器完全断开连接，相比之下，就像我们谈论的《EVE Online》一样，所有事情都大致发生在一套同质的服务器上，每个人都在同一个世界里。对于你所处的位置或你认为你要去的地方，你认为这是一个人们去到一个分区，并且规则集和社会规范存在于一个不同于另一个分区的分区中的地方吗？还是说这就像，不，其实它是完全开放的，它们之间可以平滑过渡？我认为这是一个非常棒的问题。这也是目前行业中的大问题之一，对吧？
that we're trying to make accessible. Interesting. So again, okay, a lot there to unpack, I guess. But I mean, one of the things that I hear is the different communities and different kinds of things are happening in your mind. How does that work from like, is this one giant instance? Oh, we talked about, you know, kind of like in the past gaming, right?
你有像 Facebook 这样刚刚改名为 Meta 的平台。它们正试图成为统治所有人的唯一元宇宙，对吧？一切都将发生在元宇宙的这一个实例中。这有点像《头号玩家》的愿景，对吧？有“绿洲”（Oasis）。一切都发生在绿洲中。有一个平台就是整个元宇宙。我认为这里将要发生的事情的现实将更像是 Web3 的愿景，
There's, you know, might have a server for, you know, server A and server B and server C. And you can be on one server and everything's persistent and consistent in that server, but completely disconnected from the next server, which is in contrast, like we talked about EVE Online, where everything happens on roughly like one homogenous set of servers and everyone's in the same world. For where you're at or where you think you're going, do you think this is something where people go to a partition and things and sets of rules and societal norms exist in like one partition different from a different partition? Or is this something that like, no, actually, like it's all open and like it's smooth transition between them? I think that this is a phenomenal question. And this is one of the big questions
这是一个去中心化的元宇宙，其中有许多不同的实例。这对于人类来说将是最好的结果——实际上拥有许多不同的选择，并让它们全部相互对接，对吧？创建标准，使你可以将社区从一个平台带到另一个平台，也许每个平台都为你提供不同的东西。在我看来，这有点像在问，会不会有一个所有人都会玩的游戏，对吧？会不会有一个包含所有玩家的 MMO，对吧？或者会不会有一个每个人都使用而没有其他人的社交平台？我们在科技领域的任何事情上实际上都没有看到这种情况发生。所以如果这就是元宇宙在被设想时发生的情况，那将令我感到震惊。坦率地说，所有对 Web3 的关注，以及再次说明那是共享后端、去中心化数据库、能够将你的社区、你的资产、你正在创造的体验从一个平台带到另一个平台的关注，
in the industry right now, right? You have platforms like Facebook that just changed their name to meta. They're trying to be the one metaverse to rule them all, right? And everything would take place in the one instance of the metaverse. And that's kind of the vision of Ready Player One, right? There's the Oasis. Everything happens in the Oasis. There's one platform that is the entire metaverse. I think the reality of what is going to happen here is going to be more like the vision of Web3,
我看不出任何一个平台或公司如何能够统治这样一个生态系统。好吧。我本来要问的，但我遗漏了它与 Web3 的联系——我想我们也应该对 Web3 做一个定义，但我们也许稍后再做。
which is a decentralized metaverse where there are many different instances. This would be the best outcome for people, for humanity, is to actually have many different options and to have them all interface with each other, right? To create standards where you can bring a community from platform to platform, and maybe each platform offers you different things. It's a little bit like asking, in my mind, is there going to be one video game that everybody's going to play, right? Is there going to be one MMO that has every single player in it, right? Or is there going to be one social platform that everybody uses and no other ones? We haven't actually seen that happen with really anything in tech. So it would be shocking to me if that's what happens
但是与 Web3 的这种联系，现在我听到你的意思了。所以如果世界变成了一个视频游戏，那么传统上，架构最终会变成某些公司或某个实体控制所有的资产、后端等等以及客户端。所以我想，像你所说的——这不完全是你说的，但在我脑海中浮现出来——也许最终发生的事情是，如果你想拥有一个人们在其中穿梭的持久世界，可能会有多种与其对接的方式，可能是 VR 方式，可能是 2D 网页浏览器方式，可能是各种各样的方式，但它们在后台共享某种持久性。也许你在客户端访问它的方式有一些特定的细节，但幕后可能有很多共同拥有的东西。我是否有点理解了你为什么多次提到去中心化这个联系？是的，完全正确。这就是不同前端、不同客户端、不同应用程序之间的互操作性的概念，但拥有一个统一的后端。有趣的是，我认为我们拥有一个统一后端的可能性要远大于拥有一个统一前端，对吧？或者前端只有一个选择。不过即使在后端，你知道，我们也看到了很多不同的选择。
with the metaverse as it's being envisioned. And frankly, all the focus on Web3, and again, that being shared backends, decentralized databases, being able to bring your community, your assets, your experiences that you're creating from platform to platform. I don't see how one platform or one company could just dominate an ecosystem like that. Okay. All right. I was actually going to ask, but I was missing the connection to sort of Web3, which I guess we should do a definition for as well, but we could do that maybe in a second.
随着人们对元宇宙的构想，坦白说，所有对Web3的关注，再次回到共享后端、去中心化数据库，能够将你的社群、你的资产、你所创造的体验从一个平台带到另一个平台。我看不出哪个平台或哪家公司能够直接主宰这样一个生态系统。好的。好的。我原本正要问，但我没能将其与Web3联系起来，我想我们也应该对Web3做一个定义，不过我们也许可以稍后再谈。
But the sort of connection into Web3, but now I hear what you're saying. So if the world became one video game then traditionally the architecture would end up being that some company or whatever some entity would control all of the assets the back end whatever and the client and so i guess like and what you're saying to this is not exactly what you said but in my head it's sort of coming that maybe what ends up happening is if you want to have this persistent world where people are moving through, there may be many ways of interfacing with it, maybe a VR way, maybe a 2D web browser way, maybe a variety of ways, but they share some sort of persistence in the backend. And maybe there's some specifics to the way you're accessing
但它与Web3的某种联系，现在我听懂你的意思了。所以，如果世界变成了一款电子游戏，那么传统上，其架构最终会变成某家公司或某个实体控制所有的资产、后端以及客户端。所以我想，你所说的——虽然不完全是你说的原话，但在我脑海中浮现出这样一种可能——最终发生的情况是，如果你想拥有一个人们不断穿梭的持久化世界，可能会有多种与其交互的方式，比如VR方式、二维网页浏览器方式、各种各样的方式，但它们在后端共享某种持久性。也许你在访问时有一些特定方式
it in the client, but maybe there's a lot of jointly owned things behind the scenes. Am I sort of getting why the tie-in to decentralized is something you've repeated? Yes, that's exactly right. It's the idea of interoperability between different front ends, different clients, different applications, but having one unified backend. And what's interesting is, so I think there's a much higher likelihood that we have one unified backend than one unified frontend, right? Or one option for the frontend. And even on the backend, though, you know, we see a lot of different options.
在客户端中，但在幕后也许有许多共同拥有的东西。我是不是有点理解为什么去中心化这个联系会被你反复提及了？是的，完全正确。这就是不同前端、不同客户端、不同应用程序之间互操作性的理念，但它们拥有一个统一的后端。有趣的是，我认为我们拥有一个统一后端的可能性，远大于拥有一个统一前端的可能性，对吧？或者说前端只有一种选择。不过即便在后端，你知道的，我们也看到了许多不同的选择。
Ethereum is not the only game in town. And, you know, it has the largest community. It has, you know, some legs under it and a lot of development, but it has a lot of issues as well. And what I think is going to happen is that there's going to be a few different options for backend architecture. Each of these is a standard that allows us to, on the front end, build integrations into these different backends. And then you can bring this backend information between clients. And it actually means that anybody can spin up their own client. And so I think that what's more likely than one client dominating the entire thing is actually a client engine, right? Think of like what Unity is for game development. We're likely going to see metaverse ecosystem
以太坊并不是唯一的选择。而且，你知道的，它拥有最大的社区。它有一定的基础和大量的开发，但它也有很多问题。我认为接下来会发生的是，后端架构会出现几种不同的选项。其中每一个都是一个标准，让我们能够在前端构建到这些不同后端的集成。然后你可以在客户端之间传输这些后端信息。这实际上意味着任何人都可以启动他们自己的客户端。所以我认为，比起一个客户端主宰整个市场，更有可能出现的是客户端引擎，对吧？想想游戏开发中的 Unity 是什么样子的。我们很可能会看到元宇宙生态系统
engines that allow you to just spin up your own front end and tie into this back end standard and customize it to be whatever you want. So then people can choose whether they want to bring their community that lives in this back public back end to your front end application based on whatever your specifications and specialization is. I was going to ask you to help us define Web3, but actually I think you might've just done it in sort of a way. It's like this as a broader vision. I mean, you kind of described it for a specific purpose, but I mean, is there anything else like, I mean, I guess you said you'd been in this space or whatever that you would tack on that kind of goes towards the vision of, of like why people use it
引擎，让你能够轻松启动自己的前端，并接入这个后端标准，将其自定义为你想要的样子。这样人们就可以根据你的规格和专长，选择是否将他们生活在这个公共后端中的社区带到你的前端应用程序中。我本来想请你帮我们定义 Web3，但实际上我觉得你刚刚已经用某种方式做到了。这就像是一种更广泛的愿景。我的意思是，你算是为了一个特定的目的描述了它，但我的意思是，还有别的什么吗，我的意思是，我想你说过你一直在这个领域还是怎么的，你会附带说明一些符合这种愿景的东西，比如人们为什么使用它
as a term distinct from, I guess, web two, like the current web we largely know today. Honestly, I think the, the difference between web two and web three is web two was all centralized. Every company, every application that you go to has a centralized database, a centralized backend. So you go to Facebook or something, and they have a walled garden. They own all of the information. If you're a creator and you're using any of these platforms, you need to go create within each platform very separately, right?
作为一个与网页二（也就是我们今天大部分人熟知的当前网页）截然不同的术语。老实说，我认为网页二和网页三之间的区别在于，网页二完全是中心化的。你访问的每一家公司、每一个应用程序都有一个中心化的数据库，一个中心化的后端。所以你访问 Facebook 之类的网站，他们有一个带围墙的花园。他们拥有所有的信息。如果你是一个创作者，并且你在使用任何这些平台，你需要在一个个完全独立的平台里面进行创作，对吧？
They don't have a unified standard. And so as a creator, it's actually very challenging. And that's why you don't see that many people that have a huge presence across many different platforms. So the idea of Web3, and this is maybe getting too into the weeds on it, but the idea of Web3 is actually very creator oriented. It's very community oriented. It means that you can create once in a public database that is not controlled by any one company. And blockchain really, all it is, is a way for the world to collaboratively have truthiness of that public database, right? Because no one entity controls it. There needs to be a consensus mechanism for everybody to arrive at the same
他们没有统一的标准。因此，作为一名创作者，这其实非常具有挑战性。这就是为什么你不会看到那么多人在许多不同的平台上都有巨大的影响力。所以 Web3 的理念——这可能有点过于深入细节了——但 Web3 的理念其实非常以创作者为导向。它非常以社区为导向。这意味着你可以在一个不受任何单一公司控制的公共数据库中进行一次创作。区块链其实很简单，它只是让世界能够协同拥有这个公共数据库真实性的一种方式，对吧？因为没有任何一个实体控制它。需要有一个共识机制，让每个人对什么是真的、在这个公共数据库中实际发生了哪些交易，得出相同的
conclusion about what's true, what transactions actually occurred in this public database. And the Web3 evolution is really just the shift from everything being centralized within walled gardens for each application towards something that is a shared database called, you know, using blockchain consensus methodology. Then there to be infinite number of front ends that can all share the same backend information. And as a creator, that means you can go to this backend and you can create once. And then it's up to the applications to figure out how to make your creations or your communities useful within their context, within their ecosystems.
结论。而 Web3 的演进其实只是从一切都集中在每个应用程序的围墙花园中，转向了一种被称为（你知道的）利用区块链共识方法论的共享数据库。然后可以有无限数量的前端，它们都可以共享相同的后端信息。作为一名创作者，这意味着你可以访问这个后端并进行一次创作。然后由应用程序来弄清楚如何让你的创作或你的社区在它们的上下文中、在它们的生态系统中发挥作用。
And you have a lot of choice as a creator. So in the long term, it's very likely that these are going to succeed because all the creators, if there's enough application, enough utility, and enough value being generated, then all the creators are going to choose that if they can, because, you know, there's way more leverage. And so even Topia, you know, we consider ourselves a Web3 utility. We didn't tokenize our real estate. We're not selling NFTs or anything like that. But if you have a community in a public database, if you have an NFT collection, for example, you can actually use Topia to provide superpowers to your community. You can gate access to worlds.
作为创作者，你有很多选择。所以在长期来看，这些东西极有可能会成功，因为如果存在足够的应用程序、足够的效用和正在生成的足够价值，那么所有的创作者如果可以的话都会选择它，因为（你知道的）杠杆作用要大得多。所以即使是 Topia（你知道的），我们也认为自己是一种 Web3 效用层。我们没有将我们的房地产代币化。我们没有出售 NFT 或类似的东西。但是如果你在公共数据库中拥有一个社区，比如你有一个 NFT 收藏，你实际上可以使用 Topia 为你的社区提供超能力。你可以对世界设置访问权限。
You can enable collaborative gallery creation. And so we think of ourselves as a utility layer rather than as an origination layer. And there's going to be a lot of utility layers. That's kind of the point. So when you were talking about that, I guess, in the power of the community, I always have this assumption that powerful tools need to be complicated. Like, I don't know. It's not correct.
你可以支持协作式画廊的创建。因此，我们认为自己是一个效用层，而不是一个起源层。而且会有很多效用层。这正是重点所在。所以当你谈到那个时，我想，在社区的力量中，我一直有这样一种假设，即强大的工具需要是复杂的。就像，我不知道。这是不对的。
Like, I know it's not correct, but it's like this bias, maybe as a software engineer, right? If there's a hard problem, I need to build a good tool, a good algorithm. I need to read some papers, like whatever it is, right? To get my brain going and solve it. Okay, this is probably a blindside. Anyways, but then, you know, I was playing yesterday with my kids Minecraft, which we were talking about something. They were explaining to me how Minecraft works, right? And I mentioned to them,
就像，我知道这不对，但这就像是一种偏见，也许作为一个软件工程师，对吧？如果有一个难题，我需要构建一个好工具，一个好的算法。我需要阅读一些论文，无论是什么，对吧？来让我的大脑运转并解决它。好吧，这可能是一个盲点。无论如何，但是然后，你知道的，我昨天在和我孩子们玩《我的世界》（Minecraft），我们当时在讨论一些事情。他们向我解释《我的世界》是如何运作的，对吧？我向他们提到，
I've been playing Minecraft since before you were born. I understand what Minecraft, Jason and I have been playing, played Minecraft together probably, I don't know, more than a decade ago. And like when it was really early and- To be fair, our kids are way better than we are at it, so. Oh yeah, shut up.
我从你们出生前就开始玩《我的世界》了。我明白《我的世界》是什么，杰森和我可能一起玩过，我不知道，十多年前吧。而且就像在它还很早期的时候——公平地说，我们的孩子们在玩这个方面比我们厉害得多，所以。哦，对，闭嘴。
Don't talk about that. They have a better time. But what I realized, I mean, it's much more complicated today than back then. But even this simple tool, like just a world of voxels and a couple different types and taking some down and building some up, people build like insane things from relatively basic one. And then I was also you were talking and it's not exactly web 3 obviously but i if you haven't seen it but probably most people have seen it but if you hadn't seen it for april fools i guess reddit did like are the place i don't know if you guys saw this but basically this giant canvas of blocks you could place a rate limited like one block on this giant shared canvas of some color and yet if you watch
别聊这个。他们玩得更开心。但我意识到，我的意思是，今天的游戏比过去复杂得多。但即使是这个简单的工具，比如只有一个由体素构成的世界以及几种不同的类型，挖掉一些再建造一些，人们就能用相对基础的元素建造出极其疯狂的东西。然后我也在想，你当时在讲这个，这显然不完全是 Web3，但如果你们没看过——不过可能大多数人都看过——但如果你没看过，为了愚人节，我猜 Reddit 做了一个类似于“那个画布”（r/place）的项目，我不知道你们有没有看到这个，但基本上是这个巨大的方块画布，你可以放置一个有速率限制的方块，比如在这个巨大的共享画布上放置一个某种颜色的方块，然而如果你观看
the time lapse of various communities like going in and making their users go in and click one block to one color at their you know threshold of their you know changes per second uh and then they're too small so they band with another community and they go in there and other people can overwrite their colors anyways if you've not seen, go check out the like recap videos. But one of these things that you're highlighting reminds me like this is a relatively simple thing, right? Like go in and you can make a color. But the shared context that got built around it, not only in like looking at the images
各种社区的延时视频，他们加入进来，让他们的用户参与进来，在他们的（你知道的）每秒更改次数的阈值下，点击一个方块变成一种颜色；然后他们人太少，所以他们与其他社区结盟，他们加入进去，而其他人可以覆盖他们的颜色。无论如何，如果你没看过，去看看那些回顾视频吧。但你强调的其中一件事让我想起这其实是一件相对简单的事情，对吧？去放置一个颜色。但围绕它建立的共享上下文，不仅在于在任何时间切片下查看图像
at any time slice and saying, I recognize what this is and what that is, but not what this other thing is. Or just how the communities banded together and say, this is good and that is bad. There's no consensus, but the consensus of the canvas itself, right? There's this representation. Obviously, it's Reddit. So Reddit owned all of that and made their own choices and whatever. But what they allowed people to do in the communities within Reddit to express themselves in the way that they thought was best, whether it was text or an image or a pattern or a, you know, where, where on the canvas they wanted to be, where they thought they could be.
并说，我认得这是什么，那是什么，但不认得其他东西是什么。或者仅仅是社区如何联合起来说，这个好，那个坏。没有统一的共识，但有画布本身的共识，对吧？存在这样一种表象。显然，这是 Reddit。所以 Reddit 拥有这一切，并做出了他们自己的选择，诸如此类。但他们允许人们和 Reddit 内部的社区以他们认为最好的方式表达自己，无论是文字、图像、图案，还是（你知道的）他们想在画布上的哪个位置，他们认为自己可以去哪里。
It's just like fascinating, like experiment, relatively short lived. It's Reddit. So big asterisk, if you're sensitive, you know, going and reading what all happened there but like whatever um i realize like what you're saying maybe it isn't that people need you know some big when we talk about those mmos right it's like very expensive to build the video game engine in the world the creator has to be the company as well as the engine as well as like it's all monolithic right and then you can go experience this world and do freedom things in it but like ultimately it's very controlled and what you're describing is not only the decentralization of the back end itself like you know everybody can kind of do their own thing and it's consensus own but as well as utilities
这简直是一个令人着迷的实验，存在时间相对较短。这是 Reddit。所以有一个大大的星号，如果你很敏感，（你知道的）去阅读那里发生的一切，但无论如何，我意识到你所说的话，也许并不意味着人们需要（你知道的）某种宏大的东西——当我们谈论那些大型多人在线游戏（MMO）时，这就像构建视频游戏引擎和世界非常昂贵，创作者必须既是公司又是引擎，而且这一切都是单体式的，对吧？然后你可以去体验这个世界并在其中做一些自由的事情，但归根结底它是被高度控制的，而你所描述的不仅是后端本身的去中心化（你知道的，每个人都可以做自己的事情，并且由共识拥有），而且还有效用
and pieces of the pipe and pieces of the puzzle getting conglomerated together in different ways and really distributing not that it's not a game but distributing the use of it as well like everybody participates in this creation and derives their own economics from it yeah that's that's very fascinating i i love that you just said the phrase shared context um that's one of the things that just jumped out at me because uh that is so important to the online experience or really to any community experience, right? A community really is a group of people that have a common interest. And when you come together for a community event, you have a shared context, right? You have a space that you're coming together in and you have a purpose, right? And so that actually is one of the missions of
以及管道的碎片和拼图的碎片以不同的方式组合在一起，并且真正地分发——倒也不是说它不是游戏——同时也分发了它的使用方式——每个人都参与到这个创造中并从中获取他们自己的经济利益。是的，这非常迷人。我太喜欢你刚才说的那句“共享上下文”了，这是让我印象深刻的事情之一，因为这对于在线体验或者说对于任何社区体验来说都是如此重要，对吧？社区实际上是一群有共同兴趣的人。当你为了一个社区活动聚在一起时，你们就拥有了一个共享上下文，对吧？你们拥有一个聚在一起的空间，并且你们有一个目的，对吧？这实际上也是
something like Topia is to make it really, really easy. Like you also were talking about having it be simple and not overly complicated. Our mission has been to make it incredibly easy to create a space, to create a shared context, and then bring a community together in that space. And when you think about it from a Web3 standpoint, you may have this community that exists, everybody that owns a particular NFT, which is basically just an entry in a database or a ticket. You can think of it like a ticket, right?
像 Topia 这样的平台的使命之一，就是让它变得真的、真的很简单。就像你刚才也谈到的要保持简单，而不要过于复杂。我们的使命一直是让创建一个空间、创建一个共享上下文，然后将一个社区聚集在这个空间中变得无比简单。当你从 Web3 的角度来考虑时，你可能会拥有这样一个存在的社区，每个拥有特定 NFT 的人——这基本上只是数据库中的一个条目或一张票。你可以把它想象成一张票，对吧？
And everybody that's part of that community then wants to be able to come together within a shared context, within a shared experience. And experiences are really important, shared experiences, because they're the foundation of memories, right? When you have a memory with somebody and to strengthen the bonds between individuals, you know, you really need to actually form memories with other people, which then you can reflect back on, but they serve as a foundation. And within a community, you know, your community is really only as strong as the bonds between individuals, which is based on shared memories, which are created from shared context and actually coming together. And so that is the foundation of the belief that led to a platform like Topia.
然后属于该社区的每个人都希望能够在一个共享上下文中、在一个共享体验中聚在一起。体验真的很重要，共享体验，因为它们是记忆的基础，对吧？当你和某人拥有共同的记忆，并且为了加强个体之间的联系时，你知道的，你确实需要与其他人真正形成记忆，然后你可以回顾这些记忆，它们可以作为基础。而在一个社区中，你知道的，你的社区实际上只有在个体之间的联系才有多强大，而这种联系是基于共享记忆的，这些共享记忆是由共享上下文和实际聚在一起创造出来的。所以这就是催生了像 Topia 这样的平台的信念的基础。
And it's frankly where I think a lot of this online metaverse is going, is creating these shared contexts, making it really easy for people to change the context, right? In Topia, you can very easily flip the scene. We call them scenes, but? In Tobii, you can very easily flip the scene. We call them scenes, but basically the entire world. You might be at Burning Man and then boom, now you're at like a happy hour or now you're at a music festival. You can go through a journey with your community and change context. And that's kind of a superpower. We talked earlier about replacing the real world.
坦率地说，这也是我认为这个在线元宇宙正在走向的很多方向，即创造这些共享上下文，让人们非常容易地改变上下文，对吧？在 Topia 中，你可以非常轻松地切换场景。我们称它们为场景，但？在 Topia 中，你可以非常轻松地切换场景。我们称它们为场景，但基本上就是整个世界。你可能正在火人节（Burning Man），然后轰的一声，你现在来到了一个欢乐时光聚会，或者现在你来到了一个音乐节。你可以和你的社区一起经历一段旅程并改变上下文。这有点像是一种超能力。我们早些时候谈到了替代现实世界。
It's not about that. It's about doing things that are not even possible in real life, right? Being able to switch the entire shared context with a snap of the finger is not something you can do in real life. And in fact, if you're with a community in real life and you're at an event and you're like, let's all go to the after hours bar, you lose like 50% of people in that transition. Online, you don't have to lose anybody. Oh, that's Yeah, that's interesting. You talked about about music, and I'll bring in something we haven't talked about yet. But that gets brought in this conversation too. But I'm not a big, I don't enjoy music at the way some people do. But I have been to a few concerts, and they're very noisy and messy but but you are right though like the shared
不是关于那个。而是关于做那些在现实生活中甚至不可能做的事情，对吧？只需弹一下手指就能切换整个共享上下文，这不是你在现实生活中能做到的。事实上，如果你在现实生活中和一个社区在一起，你在一个活动中，然后你想，我们大家一起去后半夜的酒吧吧，你在那个转变过程中会失去大约 50% 的人。在线上，你不需要失去任何人。哦，那是，是的，这很有趣。你谈到了音乐，我会引入一些我们还没谈到的东西。但这也会被引入到这次对话中。但我不是一个超级粉丝，我并不像某些人那样享受音乐。但我去过几次音乐会，它们非常嘈杂和混乱，但
context of being in like a place with x thousand i don't know hundreds whatever whatever the venue might be but sharing that we're in the same place and in the same time and in the same smells and sights and this particular instance of the singer performing who hopefully is not like lip-syncing but like actually performing you know is unique in some subtle ways right and that experience is very different than sitting at my computer and turning on you know whatever it is spotify google me whatever anyway there are many ways now like and listening to an album right the two are i guess like at some description and text the same like you listened to this song by this performer but like in practice as a human they're actually incredibly different experiences and the it jogged my memory of the other like obviously big player in quote
你说得对，身处一个有 X 千（我不知道，几百个，无论场地可能是多少人）的地方的这种共享上下文，但分享我们身处同一个地方、同一个时间、闻着同样的氣味、看着同样的景象，这位歌手表演的这个特定实例——他希望不是在假唱，而是真正地在表演——在某些微妙的方面是独一无二的，对吧？这种体验与坐在电脑前打开（你知道的，不管是什麽）Spotify、谷歌会议，无论如何，坐在那里听一张专辑是非常不同的。这两者，我想在某种描述和文本上是一样的——你听了这个表演者的这首歌——但在实践中作为人类，它们实际上是极其不同的体验。它唤起了我对另一个（显然是轰动的）大玩家的记忆，也就是所谓的
unquote metaverse that we hear we've not talked about but has been trying to experiment with the context of many things but uh you know i guess concerts is the one that i think is most interesting because it's disconnected from the rest is fort, right? And so Fortnite has been putting on concerts and having people go and, you know, partake in the concert in a video game that's essentially about killing all the people around you. And yet they're doing this thing that's like, completely not related to that, yet somehow works. I've not gone to one myself. but again, reading them, watching the videos afterwards, it's fascinating. Absolutely. And we've actually had many concerts in Topia as well.
我们一直在听说的“元宇宙”，我们还没谈过，但它一直在尝试各种事物的上下文，不过，你知道的，我想音乐会是我觉得最有趣的那个，因为它与其余部分脱节了，那就是《堡垒之夜》（Fortnite），对吧？所以《堡垒之夜》一直在举办音乐会，让人们去（你知道的）在一个基本上是关于杀死周围所有人的视频游戏中参与音乐会。然而他们正在做这样一件完全与此无关的事情，却不知何故成功了。我自己没有去过。但同样，阅读它们，观看随后的视频，这真是太迷人了。绝对是的。我们实际上也在 Topia 上举办过很多音乐会。
One of the really interesting things is that in the metaverse, from what I've seen, it's not the mind-blowing part of it is not actually being in front of the stage like you're in the music. That's better in person, frankly, you know, feeling the bass flowing through you and, you know, the technology in person. Yeah. But, but what's, what's crazy is it's the in-between it's walking from stage to stage, which again, in real life you can do. Um, but that's where a lot of the social interaction happens. It's away from the stage. It's in the paths between stages or on the outskirts where people are messing around and having serendipity and running into each other. And, you know, one of the challenges of Fortnite is, again, it's avatars, right? So serendipity is challenging
其中一个非常有趣的事情是，在元宇宙中，从我所看到的来看，最令人震撼的部分实际上并不是站在舞台前仿佛置身于音乐之中。坦率地说，在现实中亲临现场感觉更好，你知道的，感受低音在体内流淌，以及（你知道的）现实中的技术。是的。但是，但是疯狂的是，是中间的过渡——从一个舞台走到另一个舞台，这在现实生活中你当然也能做。嗯，但很多社交互动都是在那里发生的。它远离舞台。它在舞台之间的道路上，或者在边缘地带，人们在那里闲逛、发生偶遇、偶然相遇。而且，你知道的，《堡垒之夜》的挑战之一是，它还是头像，对吧？所以偶遇是具有挑战性的
because you see an avatar, it's nameless, it's faceless. People can troll you still because you're hiding behind, you know, a cartoon and a username. Whereas in something like Topia, which you're seeing other humans, you have crazy serendipity moments where you, in the in-between stages, you see somebody that you know. And you know that you know them because you can see them. And that kind of experience, that's what happened at Burning Man. That's what happens at music festivals in platforms like Topia. And it's pretty wild. And again, you can do that in person, but you can't do it every week. I mean, some people go to concerts every week. But it's very easy to just jump in for 10 minutes to a music experience and just try it out and go
因为你看到一个头像，它是没有名字的，没有面孔的。人们仍然可以恶搞你，因为你躲在（你知道的）一个卡通形象和一个用户名后面。而在像 Topia 这样的平台上，你看到的是其他人类，你会经历疯狂的偶遇时刻，你在两个舞台之间的过渡中，你会看到一个你认识的人。你知道你认识他们，因为你能看到他们。这种体验，这就是火人节上发生的事情。这就是在像 Topia 这样的平台上的音乐节上发生的事情。这真是太疯狂了。再说一次，你可以在现实生活中做到这一点，但你不可能每周都这样做。我的意思是，有些人每周都去音乐会。但跳进一个音乐体验 10 分钟并亲自尝试一下，然后去
mess around and have a social experience and then leave. It doesn't really cost you much in terms of time or energy or ticket costs. And so those kinds of things in the metaverse are going to be really interesting. But it's also just very much the beginning. So I actually think when we think about the, I think you asked before, you know, what is the future of the metaverse? The reality is, you know, we're in very early innings of this thing. It's like the early nineties of the, uh, the old internet. And we don't really know exactly where this is going, but the idea of the synchronous internet, this evolution, really the metaverse, when people talk about the metaverse, my definition is that it's
闲逛并获得社交体验然后离开，是非常容易的。在时间、精力或门票成本方面，它实际上并不花费你太多。因此，元宇宙中的这类事情将会非常有趣。但这其实也仅仅是个开始。所以我实际上认为，当我们思考——我想你之前问过（你知道的）元宇宙的未来是什么？现实是，（你知道的）我们正处于这件事的非常早期阶段。这就像是旧互联网的九十年代早期。我们并不知道这究竟会走向何方，但同步互联网的概念，这种演进，实际上就是元宇宙——当人们谈论元宇宙时，我的定义是它
two different things. Both are an evolution of the internet. One is towards shared backends, like we were talking about. The other is towards real-time interaction and experiences like MMOs, right? And the two together are the metaverse. And in the long term, they become a unified energy, right? A unified evolution. And this is going to play out over 15, 20 years before we get the kind of impact that the current internet with cloud computing, as an example, has from the first internet. I guess the last thing I would even just say on this is there's a lot of hype and speculation around the metaverse and Web3 and crypto. And again, it's a little bit like the early 90s when we had the dot-com boom, right? And then a massive implosion. But those kinds of boom cycles and bubbles and then implosions are actually really important
是两件不同的事。这两者都是互联网的演进。一个是朝着共享后端的方向，就像我们刚才谈到的。另一个是朝着实时交互和体验的方向，比如 MMO，对吧？这两者结合在一起就是元宇宙。从长远来看，它们将成为一个统一的能量，对吧？一个统一的演进。这将需要 15、20 年的时间才能展现出来，然后我们才能获得当前互联网（以云计算为例）从第一代互联网那里获得的这种影响力。我想我对此要说的最后一件事是，围绕元宇宙、Web3 和加密货币，有很多炒作和投机。再说一次，这有点像我们经历过网络泡沫的 90 年代初，对吧？然后是一次巨大的内爆。但这种繁荣周期、泡沫然后内爆，对于技术来说实际上是非常重要的
for technology because during the dot-com bubble, we actually had a huge amount of infrastructure get created. Fiber optic cable got laid everywhere. And then you wound up after the bust with a massive oversupply of capacity, which led to the cloud computing revolution where you had all of the supply and some brilliant person was like, why don't we decentralize access to our excess supply and charge people just based on usage and stream it over the internet? And the cloud computing revolution begins. And so we'll have probably similar kinds of boom, busts, infrastructure builds, and then oversupply and some revolution that happens in 10 years based on this. Yeah, I think that is a great point.
因为在互联网泡沫期间，我们实际上创建了大量的基础设施。光纤电缆到处铺设。然后在泡沫破裂后，你会发现产能严重过剩，这导致了云计算革命——你拥有了所有的供应，然后一些聪明人说：为什么我们不将访问我们过剩供应的渠道去中心化，只根据使用情况向人们收费，并通过互联网进行流式传输呢？于是云计算革命开始了。所以我们可能会经历类似繁荣、萧条、基础设施建设，然后是供应过剩，并在 10 年后基于此发生某种革命。是的，我认为这是一个极好的观点。
I think like having a bust or a burst of a bubble doesn't mean things have failed quite yet. And actually, not just like that infrastructure bill, but also the hard times really winnowing down to like the people who kind of have the right formula. Like you need the explosion of diversity in order to get those crazy ideas. And then when you get this like downward force selection pressure like the good ones will survive in the back okay anyways that's a great observation but we're we okay so we're getting through most of this what i want to do though is like we've talked a lot about concepts and even you know sort of topia as a concept like
我认为，出现泡沫或泡沫破裂并不意味着事情已经彻底失败。事实上，不仅仅是那些基础设施建设，而且艰难时期确实能够大浪淘沙，筛选出那些拥有正确公式的人。你需要多样性的爆发才能产生那些疯狂的点子。然后当你遇到这种向下的强力选择压力时，好的就会在背后存活下来。好吧，不管怎样，这是一个很好的观察，但我们——好吧，所以我们正在度过大部分这一切，不过我想做的是，既然我们已经讨论了很多概念，甚至（你知道的）作为概念的 Topia
what today you mentioned a few things like going between concert stages or even having like a, you know, access on to things that exist outside of Topia stuff like NFTs as a gallery or whatever, like what today is Topia as a, if I go to it, like what, what is it like, what is, what is it based on? How are you guys accomplishing that? And then, you know, we'll sort of transition a little, a little that way. Yeah. So Topia, really, it's about making it really simple to create these shared contexts for your community. So all you have to do is upload PNGs. First of all, we have a whole marketplace.
今天你提到了几件事，比如在音乐会舞台之间穿梭，甚至拥有（你知道的）对存在于 Topia 之外的事物的访问权限，比如 NFT 作为画廊或诸如此类，今天的 Topia 是什么，如果我去访问它，它是什么样的，它是什么，它是基于什么构建的？你们是怎么实现的？然后，（你知道的）我们会稍微往那个方向过渡一下。好的。所以 Topia，实际上，它是关于让为你的社区创建这些共享上下文变得非常简单。所以你要做的就是上传 PNG。首先，我们有整个市场。
We have a lot of templates. There's a ton of free content. So you can create an entire world very easily and then customize it. And it's basically endlessly, very, very deeply customizable. There's no one style of Topia. It's not like Minecraft where everything looks like the voxel-based blocks. It can look like anything you want. And so we have a lot of different examples of worlds that look like you're inside of a jungle,
我们有很多模板。有大量的免费内容。所以你可以非常容易地创建一个完整的世界，然后对其进行定制。而且它基本上是无止境的、非常非常深度可定制的。没有哪一种单一风格的 Topia。它不像《矿物世界》（Minecraft）那样，一切看起来都像基于体素的方块。它可以看起来像你想要的任何样子。所以我们有很多不同世界的例子，它们看起来就像你在丛林里面，
or look like a 2D pencil sketch office or, you know, really there's anything in between, right? It's just uploading PNGs. And then you can embed all sorts of content inside of each asset, make them interactable. You can embed YouTube, Twitch Live, or I guess live streaming with Twitch or YouTube. You can actually embed entire websites, tools, games, multiplayer games. And people use that to do things like scavenger hunts. You can do all sorts of interactive, almost borderline MMO kind of endeavors and interactions that lead to shared memories and experiences between people. So those are the kinds of tools that we're building. And we have a huge range of use cases with Intopia. So as I mentioned, we kind of launched with Burning Man in many ways,
或者看起来像一个二维铅笔素描办公室，或者（你知道的）介于两者之间的任何东西，对吧？它只是上传 PNG。然后你可以在每个资产内部嵌入各种各样的内容，使它们具有交互性。你可以嵌入 YouTube、Twitch Live，或者我猜是使用 Twitch 或 YouTube 进行直播。你实际上可以嵌入整个网站、工具、游戏、多人游戏。人们用它来做寻宝游戏之类的事情。你可以进行各种各样的互动，几乎可以说是边缘 MMO 式的努力和互动，从而在人与人之间带来共享的记忆和体验。所以这些就是我们正在构建的工具类型。我们在 Intopia 中有极其广泛的用例。正如我所提到的，我们某种程度上是以火人节起家的，
but people have had weddings, they have birthday parties. We had Asana when they IPO, they brought a thousand people together inside of Utopia World. And the CEO is doing it all hands, like speaking out and broadcasting to the entire world. But in Utopia, you can have a thousand people in a world and you click and move around. It's browser-based. It's very simple to move. Again, we tried to make it really accessible so my 95-year-old grandfather could have his birthday party in Topia. But you click and you move around and you're connecting with WebRTC over audio and video to the people that are closest to you. So people call this proximity chat or spatial chat.
但人们在那里举办过婚礼、生日派对。当 Asana 上市时，他们将一千人聚集在一个 Utopia 世界里。首席执行官在进行全体员工大会，向全世界发表演讲和广播。但在 Utopia 中，你可以在一个世界里容纳一千人，你可以点击并四处移动。它是基于浏览器的。移动起来非常简单。再说一次，我们努力让它变得非常容易上手，以便我 95 岁的祖父也能在 Topia 举办他的生日派对。但你点击并四处移动，你正在通过 WebRTC 通过音频和视频与离你最近的人进行连接。所以人们称之为邻近聊天或空间聊天。
It's basically these customizable game worlds that are browser-based and then spatial chat. It's basically these customizable game worlds that are browser-based and then spatial chat where you click and move around and connect with people that are close to you. You can also broadcast to the entire world. So you can put a podium where whoever steps up to it is broadcasting. There's a lot of different features and functionality, but people have used it for bringing the thousand people together to celebrate. We've had a lot of conferences. We have panels where a comic book launched on Topia and somebody made a completely immersive comic book walkthrough. So you can basically embed products, content, books, comics, really anything you want.
基本上就是这些基于浏览器的可定制游戏世界，然后是空间聊天。基本上就是这些基于浏览器的可定制游戏世界，然后是空间聊天，你可以在其中点击并四处移动，并与靠近你的人建立连接。你还可以向全世界广播。所以你可以放置一个讲台，任何走上讲台的人都在进行广播。有很多不同的特性和功能，但人们用它来将一千人聚集在一起进行庆祝。我们举办过很多会议。我们有小组讨论，有人在 Topia 上发布了一本漫画书，有人制作了一个完全沉浸式的漫画书漫游体验。所以你基本上可以嵌入产品、内容、书籍、漫画，真的任何你想要的东西。
And think about it almost like a website, right? So every company, every project has its own website. But when you go like a website, right? So every company, every project has its own website. But when you go to a website, you're by yourself. And it's often the directory of content. And you're kind of consuming this by yourself in directory form, not really spatial, not really that immersive. You can think about Topia Worlds as basically an enhancement. Instead of just that website, you can have a spatial world that's immersive, where you move around, go on a journey through the content, and you do it with other people. And it's persistent. So you don't have to like have a
几乎可以把它想象成一个网站，对吧？所以每个公司、每个项目都有它自己的网站。但是当你去访问一个网站，比如一个网站，对吧？所以每个公司、每个项目都有它自己的网站。但是当你去访问一个网站时，你是孤身一人的。它通常是内容的目录。而你有点像是在以目录的形式独自消费这些内容，并不是真的很空间化，也不是那么沉浸式。你可以把 Topia 世界基本上看作是一种增强。不仅仅是那个网站，你还可以拥有一个沉浸式的空间世界，在其中四处移动，通过内容进行一次旅程，并且你是和其他人一起完成的。而且它是持久的。所以你不必非得有一个
scheduled Zoom meeting for people to be able to connect and come experience something. It can just be there, it can be the community space, it can co-create it with your community, and then it can exist after whatever the event even was is over. And people can use it as that town square. And that's what we've been doing for the last two years. We've also built everything. So one of the big differences between Topia and really any other metaverse platform right now is that all of our technology is, or the foundation of it is peer-to-peer
预定的 Zoom 会议，人们才能连接并体验某些东西。它就可以一直呆在那里，它可以是社区空间，你可以与你的社区共同创造它，然后在甚至连活动都已经结束之后，它仍然可以存在。人们可以把它用作那个城镇广场。这就是我们过去两年一直在做的事情。我们还构建了一切。所以 Topia 与现在几乎任何其他元宇宙平台的最大区别之一是，我们所有的技术，或者说它的基础是点对点（peer-to-peer）
WebRTC. So when you're in a Topia world, I guess for most metaverse platforms, I'm not sure about Zencastr, but I'm assuming it's the same concept. Anytime we're talking, our audio and video is actually going through a server, right? So there's a server, either an SFU or MCU units or what they're called. And the server is getting the stream. It's doing a bunch of processing. It's taking the streams, it's putting them into one unified stream and then sending it back to you. With Topia, we are creating tunnels between anybody that you're connecting to between your devices. And so all the audio and video is not going through a server. That means that we can't transcribe. We can't record and transcribe everything that's being said,
WebRTC。所以当你在一个 Topia 世界中时，我想对于大多数元宇宙平台来说——我不确定 Zencastr 是怎样的，但我假设是相同的概念——每当我们在说话时，我们的音频和视频实际上是通过服务器传输的，对吧？所以有一个服务器，要么是 SFU，要么是 MCU 单元，或者它们的名字叫什么。服务器获取流。它做了一堆处理。它获取这些流，将它们组合成一个统一的流，然后再发回给你。而在 Topia 中，我们在你连接的任何人之间、在你的设备之间创建了隧道。因此，所有的音频和视频都没有通过服务器。这意味着我们无法转录。我们无法记录和转录正在说的一切，
whereas every other platform pretty much can. It also means for us that we have unlimited scalability, essentially unlimited scalability for very cheap. So it's very privacy oriented. It's very scalable, but it's very hard to do. And so we've spent the last two years doing that. And, you know, I've, I've been working on those technologies for the last seven years. And so, you know, it's, it's something that's very exciting for us. To be fair, we actually have a hybrid system. So you can do peer to peer or SFU,
而几乎所有其他平台基本上都可以。这也意味着对我们来说，我们拥有无限的可扩展性，基本上是以非常低的成本实现无限的可扩展性。所以它是高度注重隐私的。它非常可扩展，但实现起来很难。因此，我们过去两年一直致力于此。而且，（你知道的）我过去七年一直在致力于这些技术。所以，（你知道的）这对我门来说是一件非常令人兴奋的事情。公平地说，我们实际上有一个混合系统。所以你可以进行点对点或 SFU，
and you can switch between the two. And our broadcast, for example, is using SFU. Our peer-to-peer is how most people are interacting throughout the world and very privacy-oriented. We also have realized... We've been building since the beginning. The origin of Topia, in many ways, was to allow any organization, company, brand to create their entire own metaverse ecosystem. And so we've recently started making that available as well, is Topia as basically a backend architecture and engine where you can spin up
并且你可以在两者之间切换。例如，我们的广播使用的是 SFU。我们的点对点是大多数人在整个世界中互动的方式，并且高度注重隐私。我们还意识到……我们从一开始就在构建。Topia 的起源，在许多方面是为了让任何组织、公司、品牌能够创建他们自己的整个元宇宙生态系统。因此，我们最近也开始提供这一点，即 Topia 基本上作为一个后端架构和引擎，你可以在其中启动
your own metaverse ecosystem. And so for anybody that's interested in that, you can contact us as well. Awesome. I think that a lot of this stuff you said makes sense. And it's very refreshing to hear someone like be upfront about the trade-offs of, yeah, you know, there's a lot of great things there, but you know, there's advantages and disadvantages. And so, I mean, it sounds, it sounds really interesting. People, okay, maybe we'll transition here at the end into
你自己的元宇宙生态系统。因此，对于对此感兴趣的任何人，你也可以联系我们。太棒了。我想你所说的很多事情都很有道理。听到有人能够开诚布公地谈论权衡取舍——是的，你知道的，那里有很多很棒的东西，但你知道，也有优势和劣势——这真的让人耳目一新。所以，我的意思是，听起来，听起来真的很有趣。人们，好吧，也许我们可以在最后过渡到
talking about Topia as a company. I mean, tell us about like, I mean, obviously we kind of got a glimpse of what you're building or taste. I mean, people should go check it out. There's only so much you can do in a podcast. I mean, I've watched the videos. So when you're talking, I mean, I'm envisioning what you talked about in the videos, but definitely go check out the videos, try it out. But like, tell us about Topia as a company. Are you guys hiring? What's it like to work there? Do you guys do fully remote? Are you all in one place? How does that work? Yeah, we're remote. We do have some concentration in LA, which is where I am. Our culture is... We're a company that's making it so that you can basically have community and remote play. We're very oriented around that, right? And our values are around accessibility,
谈论 Topia 这家公司。我的意思是，给我们讲讲——显然我们对你们正在构建的东西有了一个惊鸿一瞥或初尝滋味。我的意思是，人们应该去看看。在播客中你能做的事情是有限的。我的意思是，我看过视频。所以当你在说话时，我的意思是，我在脑海中想象着你在视频中谈论的内容，但一定要去看看视频，亲自试用一下。但像，跟我们讲讲 Topia 这家公司。你们在招聘吗？在那里工作是什么感觉？你们是完全远程的吗？你们都在一个地方吗？那是怎么运作的？是的，我们是远程的。我们在洛杉矶确实有一些集中办公，也就是我所在的地方。我们的文化是……我们是一家致力于让你可以基本上拥有社区和远程游戏的公司。我们非常围绕这一点展开，对吧？我们的价值观围绕着无障碍、
human connection, safety and consent. A lot of us, probably half the team has been to Burning Man many times. And so, you know, we, you know, I would say that's kind of the vibe of it. We think of ourselves as kind of like a, everybody at Topia is really good at what they do, right? We're almost like special forces team that way.
人类连接、安全和同意。我们很多人，可能有一半的团队去过火人节很多次。所以，（你知道的）我们，（你知道的）我想说这差不多就是那种氛围。我们认为自己有点像是，Topia 的每个人都非常擅长他们所做的事情，对吧？从这个意义上说，我们几乎就像是一支特种部队。
And also very cross-disciplinary. But we don't hire anybody that is not really fired up about what we do. And we use a term called ikigai, which is a Japanese concept. It's really, it's the intersection in our context, the intersection of things that give you a lot of energy and that you are technically really good at and that drive impact. And we try for anybody that we're bringing on to figure out what is their Ikigai and is Topia and is the role that they would be having within Topia, you know, is that within their Ikigai? And Ikigai is an
而且也非常跨学科。但我们不会招聘任何对我们所做的事情不充满热情的人。我们使用一个叫做 ikigai 的术语，这是一个日本概念。它实际上是——在我们的语境中——给你带来很多能量的事情、你在技术上真正擅长的事情以及驱动影响力的事件的交集。对于我们要引入的任何一个人，我们都试图弄清楚他们的 Ikigai 是什么，Topia 以及他们在 Topia 内部扮演的角色（你知道的）是否在他们的 Ikigai 之内？而 Ikigai 是一个
amazing concept for individuals within a company. It's actually amazing concept for the company within the world. And so it's one of the ways that we think about things. But we use Topia as a remote team to have happy hours. We do stand-ups in there a couple of times a week. We do all hands. We have lots of different events and a lot of fun together through that. We also, you know, as a remote team, we get together once a quarter in person. We just did that for the first time in Denver and went to Meow Wolf, which is like an in-person experiential installation. If you guys haven't experienced it, it's pretty cool. Oh, wait, I think I read about this recently.
对于公司内部的个人来说非常惊艳的概念。它实际上对于世界上的公司来说也是一个非常惊艳的概念。所以这是我们思考事物的方式之一。但我们作为一个远程团队，利用 Topia 来举办欢乐时光。我们每周在里面进行几次站立会议。我们举行全体员工大会。我们有很多不同的活动，并通过这些活动在一起度过很多快乐的时光。此外，（你知道的）作为一个远程团队，我们每季度聚在一起一次。我们刚刚在丹佛第一次这样做了，并去了 Meow Wolf，这是一个线下的沉浸式体验装置。如果你们没有体验过，它真的很酷。哦，等等，我想我最近读到过这个。
Yeah, it's great. Okay. All right. I'm going to check this out. Is this the same one they built in Las Vegas with the grocery store that all has crazy food in it? Exactly. And that's in Area 15 in Las Vegas. And Area 15 is basically like a shopping mall where every vendor is an experience provider. And so one of those experiences in Vegas is Meow Wolf.
是的，这很棒。好吧。好的。我要去看看这个。这是他们在拉斯维加斯建造的那个里面有杂货店、里面全都是疯狂食物的同一个地方吗？正是。那个在拉斯维加斯的 15 号区（Area 15）。而 15 号区基本上就像一个购物中心，每个供应商都是一个体验提供商。因此拉斯维加斯的其中一个体验就是 Meow Wolf。
In Denver, it's a standalone installation. There's also one in Santa Fe. I think those are all the Meow Wolves, but it's kind of like a video game in real life is what it's- Yeah, I saw some video very briefly from, that's like Omega Mart or something. That's crazy.
在丹佛，它是一个独立的装置。在圣达菲也有一个。我想这些都是 Meow Wolf 的所在地，但它有点像是现实生活中的视频游戏，这就是它——是的，我从（像 Omega Mart 或类似的东西）那里看到了非常短暂的一些视频。这太疯狂了。
I'm like, it's on my list. I gotta go check this out. Definitely, yeah. It's got some like fallout vibes if you played fallout yeah okay all right we'll get off topic got off topic sorry um but okay so so i mean topia are you guys so you mentioned hiring people who are super passionate and know what they're doing i mean are you guys looking to hire do you guys do internships how does that how does that work yeah we would love uh we would love some college interns.
我觉得它在我的清单上。我得去看看。绝对的，是的。它有一些辐射（Fallout）的氛围，如果你玩过辐射的话，是的，好的，好吧，我们跑题了，跑题了，抱歉，但好吧，所以——我的意思是，Topia——你们是——你提到过招聘超级激情且知道自己在做什么的人，我的意思是，你们在寻找招聘人员吗？你们做实习吗？那是怎么运作的？是的，我们很乐意——我们很乐意招收一些大学实习生。
That's one of our initiatives right now. We are hiring across the company as well. We're likely doing fundraising towards the end of the summer. We have a lot of track time right now with our engine, as we're calling it, our sort of like metaverse engine. And that's been really, really exciting for us because we're seeing companies now being able to create their own metaverse ecosystems and be able to configure them. So one of the things for me has been creator empowerment, but also just deep customization of the experience. I want the internet of the real-time internet to have lots
这是我们目前的计划之一。我们也在全公司范围内进行招聘。我们很可能会在夏末左右进行融资。目前我们的引擎（正如我们所称的，我们的一种类似于元宇宙引擎的东西）有很多运行时间。这让我们感到非常非常兴奋，因为我们看到现在的公司能够创建他们自己的元宇宙生态系统并对其进行配置。所以对我和说，其中一件事一直是创作者赋能，但同样也是对体验的深度定制。我希望实时互联网的互联网能够拥有很多
and lots of different experiences. And that means not just worlds that look differently, but actually different interfaces, different user experiences, different experience types. And so that's, since the beginning, been part of our mission. It's now starting to connect, which is really exciting. And it means that we're going to be, you know, we are hiring right now, but we're going to be hiring a lot of additional people towards the end of the year. And so, you know, even if something's not listed on our career site, if people are really, anybody that's really passionate about this space should reach out to us because it's more important to me. I'd rather hire somebody that's really passionate about what we're doing that has a little bit less experience, or maybe where they're experienced a little bit more nebulous, right? But it's relevant to what
以及各种不同的体验。这意味着不仅是视觉上不同的世界，实际上还有不同的界面、不同的用户体验、不同的体验类型。所以从一开始，这就是我们使命的一部分。现在它开始串联起来了，这真的很令人兴奋。这意味着我们将要——你知道，我们现在正在招聘，但在年底前我们将招聘大量额外的人员。所以，你知道，即使有些职位没有列在我们的招聘网站上，如果人们真的很——任何真正对这个领域充满热情的人都应该联系我们，因为这对我更重要。我宁愿雇佣一个对我们正在做的事情充满热情、经验少一点的人，或者他们的经验可能有点模糊的人，对吧？但它与我们正在做的事情和我们要去的地方相关。
we're doing and where we're going. So we've hired... Actually, most of the people we've hired so far have been referrals or people reaching out to us. We have done less of the us reaching out or doing general solicitations or even posting on our career site. And one of the reasons is that we find that people that are referred by people already at Topia or people we trust and our allies or people that are aggressively pursuing us are more likely to get what we're doing, be really passionate about what we're doing, and be joining Topia because they believe in our mission and our vision and our values. Awesome. And then for
我们所做的以及我们前进的方向。所以我们已经雇用了……事实上，到目前为止我们雇用的绝大多数人都是内推或主动联系我们的人。我们较少主动外联、进行一般性招揽甚至在招聘网站上发帖。原因之一是，我们发现由Topia现有员工、我们信任的人、我们的盟友推荐的人，或者是积极争取我们的人，更有可能理解我们正在做的事情，对我们做的事充满热情，并且加入Topia是因为他们相信我们的使命、愿景和价值观。太棒了。然后对于
the rest of the listeners, if they go to the website today, is there something for them to check out? What would you recommend as dipping your toes in the water? Yeah, you can go to topia.io and you can create a world for free. You can use it for free forever. You can bring up to 25 people at a time for free and you can customize the world. You can put all sorts of YouTube embeds, Twitch embeds. You can embed your website. You can also, for those that are interested, you can actually embed Topia within your platform as well. And we have a lot of folks doing that within your website, within your platform. You do have to contact us and ask us for permission to do that.
其余的听众，如果他们今天访问网站，有什么可以让他们查看的吗？你会推荐什么作为浅尝辄止的尝试？是的，你可以访问 topia.io，免费创建一个世界。你可以永久免费使用它。你每次可以免费带多达25人进入，并且可以自定义这个世界。你可以放置各种YouTube嵌入、Twitch嵌入。你可以嵌入你的网站。对于感兴趣的人，你实际上还可以在你的平台中嵌入Topia。我们有很多人在你的网站内、你的平台内这样做。你确实需要联系我们并请求许可才能这样做。
We have to whitelist you. But there's a lot of ways to try this out, to embed it within your own workflow, within your own community, and to do that right now. This has been really great. I feel like it's been an awesome exploration. I think we've touched on a whole bunch, a little like, maybe a little shallow, but we covered a lot of ground and that's really great. I feel like it's been an awesome exploration. I think we've touched on a whole bunch, maybe a little shallow, but we covered a lot of ground and that's really awesome.
我们需要将你加入白名单。但是有很多方法可以尝试这个，将其嵌入你自己的工作流、你自己的社区中，并且现在就可以做到这一点。这真的太棒了。我觉得这是一次很棒的探索。我觉得我们触及了很多方面，可能有点浅显，但我们涉及的范围很广，这真的很棒。我觉得这是一次很棒的探索。我觉得我们触及了很多方面，也许有点浅显，但我们涉及了广泛的领域，这真的非常棒。
And I think this, as you said, is a space that's maturing and growing. And I feel like it's very early, so it's a bit hard sometimes to picture the trajectory, but I feel like you're kind of saying, you never know, but it feels like there's a lot of potential here. It feels like something that's been missing, something that would be awesome to have. We don't exactly know the right form yet. I mean, I'm glad to hear that there are people out there really tackling to make that more concrete. And so I'm really excited.
正如你所说，我认为这是一个正在成熟和发展的领域。我觉得现在还很早，所以有时很难想象其发展轨迹，但我觉得你的意思是，你永远说不准，但这里似乎有很大的潜力。感觉就像是缺失了什么东西，如果能拥有它会非常棒。我们还不确切知道正确的形式。我的意思是，很高兴听到有人真的在努力使其更加具体。所以我真的很兴奋。
I think this has been a great discussion. Yeah, me too. And I think what I would encourage people to think about is just like the social platforms and becoming an influencer, those that figured that out early had a huge advantage. And I think with the metaverse, it's a similar kind of thing. Just dipping your toes in, starting to become familiar. Then as this whole thing evolves, you have some context. You have some base understanding of what's going on. You've tried a few of the different platforms. And so you don't have to wait five years to try out the metaverse. It's here right now. And it's going to be beneficial to you, your company, your career to start messing
我认为这是一次很棒的讨论。是的，我也是。我认为我想鼓励人们思考的是，就像社交平台和成为网红一样，那些早期弄懂的人拥有巨大的优势。对于元宇宙，也是类似的事情。只需浅尝辄止，开始熟悉起来。然后随着整个事物的演变，你就会有一些背景。你对正在发生的事情有了一些基本的了解。你尝试了几种不同的平台。所以你不必等五年去尝试元宇宙。它现在就在这里。开始摆弄这些技术将对你、你的公司、你的职业生涯大有裨益
around with these technologies. Yeah, I feel today those influencers get a bad rap, but I kind of in line a bit with what you're saying. I don't think so. I think it's just early adopters or people who figured it out and are helping others figure it out, right? Either for their own personal gain or for helping companies connect to people or be it what you may. I mean, maybe some are more ill-intended than others, but I mean, for the most part, I just
玩弄这些技术。是的，我觉得现在那些网红名声不好，但我有点赞同你的说法。我不这么认为。我认为这只是早期采用者，或者是那些弄懂了并正在帮助其他人弄懂的人，对吧？无论是为了他们自己的个人利益，还是为了帮助公司与人连接，随你怎么说。我的意思是，也许有些人的恶意比其他人多，但我的意思是，在大多数情况下，我只是
view this as like you're saying, these are people who got on, tried to understand. And if you ever listened to a YouTube YouTuber, I guess, or like someone talk about the craft itself, the inside baseball, it's so much experimentation and trying stuff and frustration. It's not that they just like go up there and do, I mean, there's a lot of work behind it. And so I think you're right. I feel, you know, if the metaverse really becomes this like platform as a whole in various forms, the people who are early adopters are going to have a huge leg up in understanding what's been tried and what works and what doesn't work and not repeating those mistakes or
把这看作正如你所说，这些人加入进来，试图去理解。如果你听过任何一个YouTube视频创作者，或者像某人谈论这门手艺本身，内幕消息，那里面有太多的实验、尝试和挫折。并不是说他们只是走上去就做，我的意思是，背后有很多工作。所以我觉得你是对的。我觉得，你知道，如果元宇宙真的以各种形式成为这样一个整体平台，那些早期采用者在理解什么被尝试过、什么管用、什么不管用以及不重复那些错误方面将拥有巨大的优势，或者
repeating them before everyone's watching, I guess. Absolutely. And there is some overlap with influencers. We actually, within Topia, we call them confluencers. So within Topia, the influencer is a confluencer. And in nature, a confluence is where multiple rivers come together and become one. In a social context, a digital context, a confluencer is an entity that brings people together to become a community. And so empowering organizers, like everybody has those friends that are really good at just bringing people together. They're kind of like the unsung heroes of every community, of every group of friends. And what we sought to do is to empower those kinds of people to create
在所有人都在看着之前重复它们，我想。绝对是的。这与网红有一些重叠。事实上，在Topia内部，我们称他们为“汇聚者”（confluencers）。所以在Topia内部，网红就是汇聚者。在自然界中，汇聚（confluence）是多条河流汇合成为一体的地方。在社交语境、数字语境中，汇聚者是一个将人们聚集在一起形成社区的实体。因此，赋能组织者——每个人都有那些非常擅长将人们聚集在一起的朋友。他们有点像每个社区、每个朋友圈中无名英雄。我们试图做的是赋能这类人去创造
the space, bring people together and earn from doing that. And so we actually pay out a percentage of our revenue to confluencers, to what we call our confluencer ecosystem. And essentially, we're kind of like taxing companies and paying out the people that are organizing, bringing people together. they're essentially co-creating this platform and co-creating the metaverse with us. So, you know, look out for confluencers. There's an opportunity to become a confluencer right now, right? And the skills of being a confluencer and an influencer, there are some overlap,
这个空间，把人们聚集在一起并从中获利。因此，我们实际上将一部分收入支付给汇聚者，支付给我们所谓的汇聚者生态系统。从本质上讲，我们有点像对公司征税，并将钱支付给那些组织和把人们聚集在一起的人。他们本质上是在与我们共同创造这个平台，共同创造元宇宙。所以，你知道，关注汇聚者。现在就有机会成为一名汇聚者，对吧？而汇聚者和网红的技能，有一些重叠，
but, you know, it's really all about creating space and bringing people together to be, to authentically connect with each other rather than carefully crafting content that fits a persona and then broadcasting that. So it's a little bit different, but there is some overlap. I feel Jason's gig is normally the discussion of economics. I feel like you have a fair amount of thoughts here about the economics of how your platform will work and other stuff, but we're running short on time. But I think that's really interesting
但是，你知道，这实际上完全关乎创造空间并将人们聚集在一起，以便彼此进行真实的连接，而不是精心制作符合某种人格的内容然后进行广播。所以这有点不同，但确实有一些重叠。我觉得杰森的工作通常是讨论经济学。我觉得你对你的平台将如何运作以及其他事情的经济学有很多想法，但我们的时间不多了。但我认为听到有人谈论这个真的很有趣
to hear someone speak about, not like you mentioned, like how are you, people who are bringing the audience should reap a reward. I mean, I think that's a very insightful way to sort of build the business. Yeah, it just aligns with
听到有人谈论，不像你提到的，那些带来受众的人应该获得回报。我的意思是，我认为这是一种构建业务的非常有见地的方式。是的，这只与
what we're trying to do in the long-term here. And frankly, just with the people that are creating a lot of value in this real-time internet, it's one of the challenges that anybody that has played multiplayer games, especially before things with incredible matchmaking like Fortnite and Call of Duty, if you recall, when you were in a multiplayer game
我们在这里长期努力实现的目标相一致。坦率地说，对于在这个实时互联网中创造大量价值的人来说，这也是任何玩过多人游戏的人所面临的挑战之一，特别是在出现像《堡垒机》和《使命召唤》这样具有令人难以置信的匹配机制的游戏之前，如果你还记得的话，当你在一场多人游戏
and you had to sit in the waiting lobby for like five minutes as the matchmaking engine is trying to find other people to synchronously connect you with so you can play the game. That's true of the metaverse also, right? Bringing people together synchronously is kind of challenging and will continue to be challenging. So for us, we recognize that and reward those that are really gifted at bringing people together synchronously within a shared context. Awesome. Daniel, thank you so much for coming on the podcast. I feel like this has been really awesome and I've enjoyed this conversation. I know I've learned some stuff. I have a bunch to go think about now. So I was always encouraging to have a discussion with someone and leave feeling like, wow, this is really exciting. They've shared their excitement with me. And so, you know, I really appreciate
中，你必须在等待大厅里坐上五分钟，因为匹配引擎正试图寻找其他人与你同步连接，以便你能玩游戏。元宇宙也是如此，对吧？同步将人们聚集在一起是颇具挑战性的，并且将继续具有挑战性。因此，对于我们来说，我们认识到这一点，并奖励那些真正擅长在共享语境中同步将人们聚集在一起的人。太棒了。丹尼尔，非常感谢你来到这个播客。我觉得这真的很棒，我很享受这次对话。我知道我学到了一些东西。我现在有很多东西要去思考。所以与某人进行讨论并带着“哇，这真的令人兴奋”的感觉离开总是令人鼓舞的。他们与我分享了他们的兴奋，所以，你知道，我真的很感激
that. And to everyone listening, I thank you for joining us for another podcast. And we'll see you next time. Music by Eric Barndoller. music by eric barn dollar programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I, and share a like in time. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这一点。对于每一位听众，感谢你们加入我们的又一期播客。我们下次再见。音乐由 Eric Barndoller 提供。音乐由 Eric Barndoller 提供编程快报遵循知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可证分发您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品以重新混合、改编作品，但您必须署名帕特里克和我，并以相同方式共享。该剧集目前尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子以留下评论。